welcome to the beginning of my react
native web series in this series we're
gonna be building out a workout app
specifically we're gonna be modeling it
after this program called strong lifts
they have an app and we're gonna be
implementing some of the functionality
for this app specifically we're gonna go
over keeping track of your workout and
then the history of your workout and
have an app that does that and now we're
going to be building this with react
native web so what this means is at the
end of this we should have not only a
website but also an iOS and Android app
that does it for us and we should only
be having one code base or at least the
majority of its going to be a single
code base now here are the other things
that we're going to be using to build
out this app secondly we're going to be
using mob x4 state management and then
pairing with that we're going to be
using typescript as the programming
language we're going to be using react
navigation to be able to change pages in
both the app or change pages in the
website and we're gonna be using react
hooks for the entire thing and then
we're gonna be just working with the
front-end for this and so we're gonna be
storing data in local storage or async
storage on the phone so that way we can
persist the workout data as the user
uses the app or uses the website and
doesn't lose it after they come back to
it alright so in this video we're going
to setup our react native web project
now to do this you can do kind of a
multitude of boilerplates but I'm going
to be doing create react app to start
off with and then we're gonna be your
free to choose a different one if you
want to and then we're going to be
possibly using our own pack config later
if we need to change some of the config
and then we're gonna basically just be
going through the client-side rendering
portion of the react native web app
readme for now so I went ahead and ready
set up the react native or the create
react app project right here so if you
want to do the same you just go and run
yarn create and you run react app and
then whatever you want to name it and
then I did dash dash typescript to make
this a typescript project and then after
that we should see some typescript files
and
source I just have this open envious
coat right now so the first thing that I
want to do is I want to add react native
to this project so I'm gonna say yarn
add and I'm gonna install a react native
react native web and then this package
called react art or react art which
react native web needs now I'm trying
something new for this series you'll
notice I have versions at the end of all
of these the reason for that is I'm
going to be trying these exact versions
so you can follow along with me and
hopefully as the series progresses there
won't be any changes with you installing
a later version of the package also the
other thing you're gonna want to make
sure you install react native 0.55
because if we take a look at the react
native web documentation it's compatible
with that version and not higher so
we'll go ahead and install these three
packages and then we're gonna install
the types or react native that way we
have type definitions when we use
typescript with it so we're going to say
yarn add as a dev dependency and we're
going to be adding react native and I
can just bring that up so you can see it
better
and again I'm installing the types at
version 0.55 just so that matches up so
after we have installed those things
we're ready to basically take out some
things from the create react app which
we just do not need so for example we do
not need the SVG index that CSS app or
app test or app dot CSS so I'm just
gonna go ahead and just delete those now
and then in the index dot tsx file you
can go ahead and delete this line right
here and then we're going to paste in
this client-side rendering code right
here
and so now we're just going to remove
this react Dom render instead of us
saying react Dom render we're just going
to be using this app register now notice
ours is called routier this get element
by ID so we're just gonna rename this to
root right here as well and the way that
we're going to go throughout the series
is I think we're going to build out a
react native web or that least the
website and then at the end we'll get it
working
with the app or maybe in the middle will
spin up also the app and make sure that
is working but we're gonna primarily
develop this from the website point of
view and basically the process of doing
this is we're actually going to just be
writing all our code using react native
import so you'll notice we've imported
from react native here we're gonna be
importing from react native the entire
time through our code alright so I'm
gonna go ahead and save this and it's
going to remove those dead imports at
the top I have it so a BS code setting
so it does that for me if you want to
turn that on you can go to preferences
settings and if you come click on the
brackets over here you can see the
bracket versions of your settings and I
believe one of them I have organized
imports yeah so this editor dot code
actions on save I have it automatically
running organized imports so you're
gonna see that throughout the series
happening so now that we have this
initialized in our index tsx we want to
just go into our app itself and convert
it to using react components or react
native components so let's just app top
TSX right over here and we're not going
to be using classes we're gonna be using
function components and hooks so I'm
gonna say Const app and here we're just
gonna say return and also the other
thing I want to mention is probably
throughout this I'm going to be using
some different shortcuts so I'm gonna be
posting my vyas code settings below if
you want to get these as well so one of
them I have is called R and SS so this
is going to create style sheets for me
so we're going to be using style sheets
from react native to do this so these
are little snippets
and also I have rh4 react took and so
this is going to spit out a snippet that
looks like this and so here I can say
the name my component app and this one
doesn't take any props so I can just say
say it like that
and now I can put whatever stuff I want
here anyway I'm gonna get delete all
this stuff we don't need any of that
code right there and I can get rid of
all this stuff here and basically we can
empty the file and just have this and we
don't need to export this so now we're
gonna actually be using react native
components here so I'm gonna save you
and then we're gonna say text and we're
going to say hello from the AK native
web and of course we need to import all
these and I can I just hit command and
then period this is another one you're
gonna see me do throughout the series to
import things I can either import just
this view or import all missing imports
the other thing you'll see me do is if I
have my cursor here I can hit command in
space to autocomplete get this menu up
both of those I'm going to be constantly
through doing throughout the series so
it's good to add those to your
repertoire as well and yeah the text we
want to also import I just did command
period and it doesn't look like it's
laying me import it so usually I'll hit
command space - oh sorry control space
and I'll bring it up and you can see I
want to auto import from react native
we'll hit enter all right so this is
what the start of our applications gonna
look like if I come back over here we
need to start the server up say yarn
start and then when this boots up we can
go to localhost 3000 and it's going to
actually render the view in the text and
so the thing with create react app is
underneath the hood what it's going to
do is it's going to change react native
to react native web and it's going to be
using those components and then react
native web turns the view component into
divs and I guess the text component
maybe also into divs but anyway we can
see the text right here show up we can
even inspect this and see what the heck
it created for us you'll notice with
react native web it's
that a whole bunch of classes for us
that's an interesting thing I noticed
but anyway that's kind of your
introduction to react native web of how
to set it up recap of what we did is be
installed three packages react art react
native and react native web and then
inside our index TX we initialized our
app using this bit of code that we got
from the readme instead of the react Dom
and then in our app we're just going to
go ahead and continue to flush out this
thing using react native components
so before we go any farther I want to
make sure we can get react native set up
with react hooks so that's what we're
gonna be doing in today's video and
start off with we're going to be using
the react native CLI now usually when I
start a react native project I'll
usually opt for Expo just because the
development experience is a lot better
and you can start up the emulator and
build the application a lot faster but
as of today or currently they do not
support react hooks at least I don't
believe they do so we're just going to
be using the react native CLI for this
so to do so we are going to first
install it and we're installing obli by
running this command npm i - g and i
already have it installed globally so
I'm just going to interrupt it next
thing we're going to do is run the CLI
to create a project and react native so
we're building the project in typescript
so we're going to follow this guide
right here and we're just going to run
this command right here and I've already
done this initialized a my awesome
project and that's what I have open vs
code right here so after that the first
thing I'm going to do is if we look at
our package of JSON you'll notice that
they have two dependencies react and
react native so we want to set up hooks
in this project so we're going to need
the latest version of react or at least
react 16.8 and then for react native
we're going to need version 259 to work
so we're going to install both of those
so we're gonna say npm i and install
react at version sixteen point eight
point two and react native at point five
nine and this is currently a release
candidate so that's why there's this -
Arcia so we're gonna go ahead and
install that and then especially with
react native you might have saw our
mention last video that with react
native web it's only compatible with
0.55 and we're currently using we just
installed five nine to use in this
particular project so this is what i'm
going to attempt and we'll see how well
it works is i'm going to be using 5 9 in
the react native project this one and
then our web project
we're gonna be sharing the same
components but we'll see if we can get
it working the components even though
we're not we're gonna try not to rely on
any react native five nine features that
would break the react native web project
but we'll see how that goes anyway so we
got this installed so we can go to the
app tsx so this is what's currently
being rendered if we were to start the
app right now I'm gonna just delete the
app dot J s because we do not need it if
you click on it you'll notice it has the
flow version if you want to use flow but
we're gonna be using typescript all
right so we're just gonna write out a
simple hook to make sure this works so
I'm gonna say down here just export
defaults app and then I'm going to
convert this into a function so I'm
gonna say Const app and then this is
going to just return and then I'm gonna
just copy the view and then we're going
to say Const use state and we're just
gonna create a little counter to make
sure it works so here I'm going to say
count and set count and then here I'm
going to display the current loops
current value of count and then below
that we're gonna render a react native
button we're going to say increment and
then whenever you press this we're just
going to say set count is equal to count
plus one and we're gonna give that a
save we don't really need the props here
and now if we go to our package of JSON
we want to run this project so we can
start the CLI or the packager by running
yarn start or NPM start the next thing
that we have to do is actually start the
emulator itself so I'm gonna be running
the iOS simulator so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna say iOS here and I'm gonna
say react
negative run iOS now for those of you
that are on a Windows computer you're
going to need to use Android and you're
going to need to have Android studio
installed and have an emulator created
and when you have both those things you
can create an Android script here and
you just say run Android and you want to
make sure I believe your Android
emulator needs to be running when you
run this command but if for the iOS one
it'll automatically stir it up for you
so we're gonna say npm run iOS and just
a heads up this will probably take a few
minutes to actually build this on the
emulator and get it all working and then
we'll see our application and make sure
it works so mine finished building and I
can see the app starting up here now if
you don't see it started up what should
happen is if you go to just the screen
with all the apps there should be a new
icon it should say my awesome project or
whatever you named your project and you
can just open that up to see it so if we
go ahead and click this we can see it's
incrementing the state so it will hooks
are indeed working with react native
right now so where we're gonna go from
here is we can now have our react native
project set up and we also have our
react project set up so the next thing
is is we're going to set up a mono repo
it's that way we can create basically at
one code base that we're sharing with
our react native setup and with a react
set up and basically that one module or
package that we're going to share
between both of them and we'll set that
up
so we are now
set up a mono repo and the reason we are
doing this so it's easy to share the
code between the react and the reactive
project that we set up already now I
just did a step before I started this
video I created a folder which I just
called my mono repo and then I took the
two folders or projects that we worked
on in the last two videos and put them
in here so I copied the my awesome
project into this folder and I also
copied the react native web series and
this react native web series is just
what I called the project that we
created with create react app so I'm
gonna be starting from here and the
first thing that we're gonna do is set
up yarn workspaces so in my mono repo
once you have these copied over we're
going to create a folder called packages
and then I'm gonna rename my awesome
project to app and that's where the
react native codes gonna go and then I'm
gonna rename this to web and I'm gonna
put that in packages so here's what our
file structure looks like right now and
then next I'm going to say MPM I - why
or an it /y
to initialize a repo here or a package
of JSON I mean and then to actually make
it into a yarn workspace we need to say
at the top here private is equal to true
and we're gonna say I'll just add this
at the bottom workspaces and then here's
where we specify what our workspaces are
we're gonna say packages slash star so
what that means is any thing that we add
in the packages folder is going to be
considered a package that yarn
workspaces are gonna see and be able to
do stuff with so now if I were to run
yarn right now it should install all the
dev dependencies for everything and I'm
just gonna real quickly just remove
perfect air you have this up all the
node modules and all these packages so
remove it
and remove it in web and I can do it
with this command so I'm saying remove
RF packages and then I'm saying
doesn't matter what package you can do
that with the star command and then
remove node modules you could also just
go into each package and but there's
only two right now that's a little
shortcut for you all right so I deleted
that I'm just gonna go ahead and run
yarn and I'll let this run in the
background because it's gonna probably
take a few minutes like and so all that
stuff so next thing that we're going to
do is we're gonna create a new folder
which we're gonna call common so common
is basically where we're gonna start
we're gonna be developing stuff most of
the time so this is where the one code
base is going to live and then both the
app and the web are gonna use this one
code base so I'm gonna go inside of
packages common and we're gonna just
initialize this with a package of JSON
as well now I'm gonna give this a it's a
refresh there we go I'm gonna give this
a name I'm just going to call mine
Wow so whenever you deal with yarn
workspaces or mono repos in general
usually you'll have the name of your
mono repo and you'll say at the name of
your monitor both slash the name of the
individual package this case I'm just
naming my monetary bow-wow and that's
what I'm gonna put here next up we're
going to create a source folder and
inside of there I'm going to say indexed
TSX and here I'm just going to paste
just a demo app and the one that we
created so if I go to app app with TSX
I'm just gonna copy the app that we
created so copy this paste it in and of
course we need to install react and
react native and stuff in here so let me
just make sure this is finished running
it is cool so in here I'm going to say
yarn add we're gonna add a reactive and
react and we're going to add react out
sixteen point eight point two all right
so when that is done we're then going to
install the dev dependencies or react
native and then we're also going to
install the typescript and then we're
gonna have to add a TS config to this
so let's do that and I am installing
this as typescript three point three
point three and then this is just the
latest types for react native even
though we're using a later version
reactive itself this is kind of the
latest types all right so now we can say
here I can just import this all from
react native or whatnot that's taking a
second to load instead of me manually
importing this I'm going to just give it
a second and we're gonna create a TS
config alright so in our TS config I'm
just gonna copy what we have in the web
and then we're gonna make a few changes
so for this we're gonna say allow J s
we're gonna remove that we don't want to
allow J s instead of isolated modules
we're gonna say declaration is true and
when we set declaration is to true we
build the module what's gonna happen is
it's gonna have type strip declaration
files in it which is what we want and
here we're gonna say JSX is going to be
react and then no omit I'm gonna get rid
of that and then module I believe we
need to change this to common J s and
then I'm gonna say an out directory I'm
gonna say is dist and I believe that's
all the changes that we need to make to
this file but when we build a project
and then try to use it we'll see if we
have any problems alright so this should
be good loading it is so I'm just going
to say a command period and import
everything in and it looks like Tex
didn't get imported for some reason so
control space and we'll import that and
its style sheet get added nope there you
go instead of export defaults I'm just
going to export it like that and that
looks pretty good and the package.json
we are gonna say yes TSC and i'm gonna
rename this to build and what this does
is this runs the typescript compiler and
the compiler code so if i come here say
yarn builds and it's going to look in
the source folder build it and we
see the dist so a couple things if you
know this work correctly is in your
distal der should see an index dot DTS
should just look like this I guess and
then in your index dot JSS and you'll
notice that there's not JSX in here
right so it does not look like this
where there is brackets and stuff that's
JSX
it looks like this and we were saying
create element in here so that's
important yep so that is pretty much all
you need to do in common I believe so
next we want to basically use this code
base in both these projects so today
we're gonna start by adding it to the
web so to do that we're gonna head over
to the web stack atop JSON and we need
to first add the common package as a
dependency so I usually just come in
here and I say wow slash common and then
we're gonna set the version of it and if
we come to common package of JSON it'll
tell us the version is just 1.0 oh
that's the wrong one so we're gonna put
that there
and then after we add that we just need
to say yarn so we're gonna CD over to
the web and that's just going to add
this common package in here and now if I
go to my app dot TSX
instead of just saying hello from react
native web what I'm going to do is
delete this app and I'm just going to
export the app which we get from that
package which we said is well slash
common alright and let's see if
currently cannot find it I'm not sure
I'm I just hit command and then P or if
you command capital P it will open this
little window I'm gonna restart the
typescript server to see if it actually
can find the module the other thing you
can do to double check is if I do an LS
node modules I'm able to see whether or
not it was added and we can see at Wow
is not there so that means it didn't get
added for some reason so I either messed
something up or it didn't get added for
whatever reason so I'm just gonna say
yarn again or you know what I'm just
gonna remove the node modules altogether
and just have yarn run again
and see if it gets added this time oh
you know what we forgot one important
step that's why it's not working so if
we go back to our common package.json if
we look at this main we need to specify
where the main file is so for us it's
going to be inside of dist and an index
KS so let's add that real quick all
right so now we're gonna just I don't
know if we need to re yarn if I go back
to the app oh cool
so you notice how it just went from red
to orange I don't know if you're
watching right there it also is no
longer in error here so it was able to
find this file now so we're gonna say
yarn start and we're gonna get this
error about skip pre-fight check or that
we did some things wrong and it's gonna
tell us some things are wrong basically
we're trying to access a module outside
and maybe we're doing some other stuff
wrong but we can just add this skip
preflight check to the beginning and
everything will work so let's go ahead
and do that
so skip pretty flight check is true now
for those of you guys that are on
Windows to get this to work we can add
cross and in front of this so I'm now
gonna add cross and as well and it
doesn't matter what version of cross and
you get it should probably work and that
just makes this work on Windows alright
so let's do yarn start again and if this
works correctly what happens when this
starts up is we should see this little
app counter that we have where we can
click on it and it's gonna increment the
count using hooks in our website so it
looks like no crashes come over here we
see our little welcome to react native
can increment and that's our hooks
working so awesome so what we just set
up is a common package which we are now
using in the website so getting this to
work with reactive is also a little
tricky so that's what we're gonna save
till the next video and so we're gonna
import basically this common package or
get the common package working with the
app as well and so what's going to
happen is in the future
we're just gonna be coding in this
common folder and then both the web and
the app is gonna get this code and
should basically be building the app and
the website in parallel now I just want
to go over real quick a few things that
is important about what we set up
because this can be kind of tricky to
get working so if is not working for you
these are the few things that you want
to check so you notice I was coming over
here and I was saying LS no modules and
confined it I think what I was doing
wrong about that is one it should be in
the root folder and there it is if I do
LS dadada thought in the root directory
or the root mano-a-mano repo we can see
the Wow
folder and we can see common so that is
important to be able to see so the thing
is again this was important we missed
this at first you want to make sure that
you have index or this dist
this main is pointing at an actual file
that exists and that's pointing at this
slush index dot JSON to add real quick
is I'm gonna add this thing called rim
ref so this is gonna delete the build
folder or this dist folder every time we
build that way we don't have stale data
in there so I'm gonna say Ram wrap dist
and we're gonna build okay so I'm gonna
a CD back over to common and yarn add as
a devta sincere m raff and this doesn't
really matter what version either and so
what that's gonna do is it just going to
delete the folder and then it's going to
build it each time and if we do yarn
build nothing will really change but
that just helps get consistent build
sometimes we get funky stuff when I
don't do that the other thing is with
the TS config there's a couple important
things
make sure the JSX is set to react make
sure that the module is common GS and
the last one is declaration is set to
true and so when you build stuff you get
a nice disk that has the right output
that we want and notice we're saying
include source here that's how we know
it knows to build the source folder
right there as well
and that's pretty much the key parts of
getting this to work I think and then
after that we just add of course this to
our
package.json the Wow package or the
common while package
we're gonna use this common package that
we created and use it in our app package
which is based on react native now
getting yarn workspaces and importing
from our your workspaces is actually a
little tricky
with react native and we're gonna see
why that is in a couple minutes as we
kind of run into some of these issues
and we'll deal with some of the
workarounds to get it to work so to
start off though we are going to just
install or add the dependency to our
package of JSON in our react native
project so I'm gonna say at Wow / common
that's just what I named it and I'm
gonna put version 0 here and then I can
go to the memory and the packages app
right here and I have yarn to install
that after that and the app TSX I'm
gonna just replace all this code that we
have here with the app so I'm gonna
delete this like this delete this and
then the app is going to be coming from
that common package and then here if I
just say app we can have this is what we
want to render now if we try to just
starting up the application right now
we'd actually get in air we can try that
if you want so we can say yarn start and
it's going to say cannot find module now
if we go to our package of JSON we can
see why that is so it's trying to start
the react native CLI and you'll notice
the path it's looking for node modules
and then the react native one and if we
just do an LS to see if that exists
react native will actually see that the
file does not exist or the directory
does not exist and the reason for that
is we are using a yarn workspace and so
how yarn workspaces work is they hoist
up the modules so what that means is
it's actually sitting in our root
directory so if we do an LS and we go up
to directories into that node modules
and we look for the react native package
you'll notice we will find it that's
because it was hoisted
so we can avoid this problem because we
basically want it in this current
directly current directory we could lift
it up if we wanted to but I'm going to
say no hoist so this is a trick that you
can use with yarn workspaces and how it
works is we can specify either in the
root directory we could use that or in
the child directory which we're going to
be using no hoist on the react native
package so I'm gonna copy this and I'm
gonna paste it and my dev dependencies
or sorry not my dev dependencies but in
the package of JSON at the bottom and
I'll link a link to this article this
kind of goes more in depth about how no
hoist works but basically what's gonna
happen is the react native dependency
instead of being in the root node
modules it's gonna come down to the node
modules that is in the app now whenever
I add a change like that like I just
added the no hoist option here I like to
just destroy the node modules and
reinstall them because usually stuff
gets messed up in the middle also I just
saw this was being unsaved I'm just
gonna save all right there all right so
I'm gonna do remove and I'm gonna remove
RF both the node modules that's in this
current directory and also just the
route as well just to be safe
sometimes stuff gets messed up now the
next problem we're gonna hit is after we
get this it's gonna be able to start up
ok but what happens with yarn workspaces
is to be able to access this common
package and to be able to make changes
to the common package and not having to
do a yarn install every time is they use
symlinks now one of the downsides of
react native or one thing that doesn't
work with react native very well right
now is symlinks so what we're gonna have
to do is work around it so one option to
work around it and that worked out real
quick we'll talk about how we're gonna
handle symlinks in a second let's just
look if our node modules worked so if i
do an LS on this node modules slash
react native you notice it's now here so
if I were to do a yarn start it should
indeed start the packager now the other
thing I just wanted
mentioned is I have my application up
and running over here or my simulator
and if I try to reload this right now it
should have a problem yeah perfect
well not perfect but here's the air at
Wow slash Colin does not exist in the
haste module map so this is where it
can't basically get the sim link that
we're using for that now one thing I
want to mention real quick is to start
up my simulator over there I just did
yarn i OS which ran this over here let's
start up the simulator and the other
thing is when I was starting it up
because I moved this into a different
folder when we were setting up the
workspace there's this iOS build folder
right here that has a basically cached
version of the build and it had the
relative directories all messed up so I
didn't delete this build folder to get
that to work so you may have to do the
same thing if you were on Mac I'm not
sure if there's equivalent for Android
doesn't look like it all right so so we
started that we need to handle this next
error now I'm not sure the best way to
handle some links in react native right
now I'm not sure if there's a standard
way because the default bundler that
comes with react native I don't believe
works with it and there's a ton of open
issues about it so hopefully they'll be
fixed soon but one way that's super easy
to fix it is this this one library
called WM L and basically what this does
is we can just specify a directory so
for us we're going to specify the common
directory and it's going to basically
copy over the files every time we make a
change so we're gonna be using that so
if you don't have this already install
on your computer you're just gonna run
npm install and it's going to install
globally so after that we're going to do
is ctrl C this is we're going to say add
and we're gonna run this command right
here so we're gonna go up a directory
and get the common folder and then we're
gonna put it into our node modules at
Wow slash common so you'll notice here
this is just the name of the package and
here's where the local directory is
alright so if I do add I'm gonna say yes
ignore node modules
then what I can do is wml start so now
what's going to happen is anytime I make
a change in the common folder over there
it's gonna copy over all the files and
where it's gonna copy is that node
modules slash Wow if we take a look at
that we can see funny enough it looks
like our app is here I'm not sure why
that's there slash common and we can see
our code is there now I don't actually
want it kind of looked pink there and I
don't want it to be pink because that
usually means it's a simply but let's
just see if this did fix it
so you're on start and if it didn't I'm
just going to delete it and then
recreate it so let's reload this yeah
see I didn't think it would and I'm just
going to it's doing LS on it again just
to make sure okay when I do an LS here
it showed it like that but if I did an
LS here oh this is because I'm in the
root directory
that was just my bad alright let's come
back over here so one thing I noticed
about the error is it's coming from
react or it's coming from not being able
to find the module react so what we can
do is we can say no hoist on react as
well as react native and that should be
able to find it so I'm going to just
copy paste this and I'm going to say
react here instead of react native give
that a save and then I'm just gonna
remove the node modules and the parent
reason being if I remove them locally
it's going to destroy kind of our sim
link setup or our wml setup so I'm just
going to say they remove the root one
and do yarn and that should add it for
us and then when this is done what we
can do to double-check this works is
again we can just do an LS on the node
modules and make sure that is all there
another thing is to make sure your WL or
w ml thing is working is you can go to
packages app and if we do an LS there on
common oh it's mine I guess it depleted
mine even though I didn't want to delete
all right we can just restart it so ctrl
C and we'll restart that and let's come
back over here
alright so it exists and if I go into
dist you should be able to see the index
Ras that's all good because this is what
we're actually importing is that index
that is from the dist folder so you want
to make sure that's there and now we
should have a node modules react it
should probably be done loading yeah so
I'm gonna come back and just say yarn
start and start the package er I'm gonna
get this running alright cool so that
looks like it's able to load down and we
can increment it so it's working so as
you can see it's a little tricky to get
this set up but the gist of it is we had
to know hoists and things so bring some
modules down so in our case we had to do
react native and react and then after
that the other tricky part is making
sure that the packages that were using
our sim linked or in this case we didn't
want them sim linked so we had to bring
them over by using wml and to do that we
said add and then we say start which
actually moves them over now whenever we
make changes to the comment it should
move it over so we don't need to do
anything there as long as we have this
up and running the other thing is if we
were to add more packages we wanted to
depend on we'd have to wml add now there
are some other ways to achieve this same
thing I believe in the past I've played
around with I believe it's called like
react native config or something where
you can kind of get it I don't know if
that solves the symlink problem or if it
solves the no hoist problem but one of
those but it can be a little harder to
set up where this is not too bad to set
up so I figured we start here and if we
run into more problems we can
investigate that later and then the only
other
as we program stuff in the future we're
gonna be basically just doing stuff in
the common folder and then the app
should be getting the updates and the
web should be getting the updates at the
same time and I'm pretty much just gonna
focus on what it looks like on the web
just because it's a lot easier to get
set up and to also just view it and
watch the renders in real time versus
react native
we're gonna be going over how you can
use mob X with react hooks to start off
we're gonna install two libraries in the
common package the first one is going to
be mob X at version 5.9 and then we're
gonna be using mob X react to light a
version 1.01 and this library is gonna
allow us to actually get it working with
hooks so we're gonna head and install
that and for those of you that are not
familiar with mob X what we're gonna be
using it for is state so it is a state
management library now to start off
we're gonna be inside our common package
I'm gonna go to source and create a new
file I'm going to create a folder
outside which I'm gonna call stores and
we're gonna say counter store TS so here
I'm gonna say class counter store I'm
just going to close that and we're gonna
have a single field which I'm going to
call count and then have a default value
of zero now I want to make this field
observable so we can do that with mob X
by saying observable and we're gonna
import that and that's coming from mob X
now it's gonna complain about this if we
hover over you can see tells us we do
not have experimental decorators turned
on so we can go over to our TS config
and turn that on and so here gonna say
decorator it's gonna be this
experimental decorators set to true if I
give that a save and come back over here
it should no longer be complaining about
this now and I'm gonna say export Const
and we're gonna say counter store
contacts and we're going to say create
context and that's coming from react and
then we're gonna say new counter store
and give that a safe now this counter
store context is what we're going to use
in our components and then we can
basically interact with the store that
way so now in our index FTS we had a
basic example before where we were using
use state to store the state of a
counter and then we are incrementing it
so now we're going to start by making
this work with mob X we're going to
start by wrapping it with an observer
and we're gonna just wrap it the entire
function there and now observer is
coming from that other package we
installed so that's mob X
react light observer and then here
instead of using you state we're gonna
say Const counter store is equal to use
context so we're using the used context
hook and then we're gonna pass in the
counter store context that we created so
now what I can do is I can say counter
store dot count to display the count and
then when I press on the button I can
say counter store dot count and then we
can just directly mutate it by
incrementing it so cool so now I want to
see this and see if it works
so to start off I have my server already
running for the website so I have that
up and I'm just going to compile the
code here so I'm gonna go to the
package.json
and I'm gonna add a new flag that'll
make this a little easier called watch
and so we're gonna say TS TS c and we're
gonna say - watch and so what's gonna
happen is we run this so yarn watch it's
going to compile our code and watch for
any changes we make and recompile it
alright so here is our website just give
this a refresh and then if we increment
notice that worked just the same as it
did before
so pretty cool and mob exit looks pretty
sweet being able to just mutate it like
that is pretty simple I like that so of
course we're gonna be using mob X for
the state management for our application
so we're gonna be using it to store
basically the state for working out or
for workouts so we're gonna start by
creating a new store today and I'm gonna
call it the work out store and here I'm
gonna say class work out store and today
we're just gonna map out kind of a few
different things that we're gonna store
in this so there's basically four
different or five different exercises
that this workout uses so we're going to
store that all in the store and we're
also going to start out by kind of hard
coding things and then we're gonna go
back later and possibly make this
generic and work with say any set of
exercises so the for exercises is squat
or five exercises squat
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna call
this current squat and when I say
current squat this is what it stands for
is kind of like how much are you
currently squatting and this is gonna be
a number so for example you may be
squatting 500 pounds or 100 pounds and
we're gonna track that in this variable
let's see why it's unhappy it has no
initializer let's turn that setting off
for now initializer strict property
initializers as I think what we need
this turn off to be able to get rid of
that warning say false and cool and then
we're gonna say squat bench press
overhead press overhead press and I
guess let's be consistent I said press
there do it press there deadlift and
that'll be a number two and then lastly
is the barbell row all right so these
are the five exercises again I've kind
of hard-coded here we could also go with
the approach where we kind of have this
in an array but I'm going to start dead
simple and then we're gonna kind of
refactor things out and make it more
dynamic as we go we also need to know so
how the workout works is we're gonna
have two different days like a a day in
a B day and so we need to know what our
last day was because we do a different
exercise on each day so for example I
don't know maybe on the a day you do
squat bench deadlift and on the B day
you do squat overhead barbell something
like that so we're gonna say last
workout type and we're gonna make that a
union so we're going to say workouts
type is equal is either in a day or B
day
and so that's going to be of that type
workout type or why don't I call this
workout day that makes more sense either
in a day or B day so we're gonna say
last workout day well I don't think last
workout day really makes sense we'll say
the last workout type is fine and let's
make a lower case oh I suppose and then
the last thing that I can think of at
least to start off with is we want to
know what the history of what lifts that
you've done and so we can keep track of
that and the way I want to keep track of
it is kind of a dictionary that way we
can keep track of in the key being the
date so what I'm thinking is create an
interface which we're gonna call history
call it workout history not to confuse
it with any other type of history like
browser history or something
so the key I'm thinking is going to be a
string representing the date we're gonna
say key of string and here I don't think
I need to say key I like just say key
and then the value of this is going to
be I guess an array and the array is
gonna have basically the values for that
day so here I'm gonna call this the
movement or the exercise is a better
name exercise is a string and then the
value which is a number so for example
what that might look like is I'm
thinking something like this so on the
18th so let's see what month is it I
don't know like oh 2 18 20 19 there's
gonna be the key and then the value is
gonna be array that looks like this and
then the exercise might be squat and
then the value might be like 90 so this
day you squatted 90 pounds and then
right maybe also benchpress that day I
do that for a hundred pounds
so this is what I'm thinking the data
structure be and we may improve this
data structure a little bit and add more
fields to this later on but this is on
thinking for the start of it anyway this
is kind of the start of our store let's
go ahead and just add the type real
quick and then the next video is we're
gonna continue kind of working on this
store and start adding some components
to start rendering some things for it
but before we end this video let's just
export this so export Kant's workout
store context is equal to create context
new workout store
so as one
to go over navigation today specifically
adding a button here that was like start
workout and then we'd be transitioning
to a new screen and to that I was
planning on using react navigation
because I saw they have a react native
web version and it works really nice for
a react native so it'd be nice to be
able to use it but after I tried out the
example I saw the react knee of what web
1 was kind of just meth and I didn't see
a great way to integrate it so we could
have one kind of routes that would work
for both the native and for the web I
didn't see a great way to do that and
they didn't have typescript types so I
was like let's go check out how dev hub
does it to see how they were doing
navigation and it turns out they
actually have just a ternary operation
and they have just two screens a login
screen and a main screen and that's how
they're picking and our application is
not too complex so I figured we might as
well do it in a similar manner and use
mob X to keep the state and just kind of
have a ternary where we switch which
page were displaying because react
navigation at least for the web seems
like it still has some time before its
production ready slash really a good
choice so that's we're gonna do in
today's video so I have the app up or
the website up and we're gonna create a
in the common package a new folder here
and I'm gonna call this routes actually
I'm just gonna create it as a file call
it routes at tsx and this is gonna
basically where I'm gonna store it
some say export cost routes and we're
gonna return null for now now I said
we're gonna store this in mob X so I'm
going to create a new store which I'm
gonna say router or I guess route routes
store I don't know if that's the best
name for it and when I come over here
and just copy the counter example
so routes actually no I like router
store better just thinking about it
let's go matches this better I guess
well I guess I call that routes oh well
so I'm gonna say a router store here
router store context and then I'm gonna
say this is gonna be a path and the
default path I'm gonna say is the home
page which actually I'm gonna call the
home page the history page because I
think we're gonna store the workout
history on the front page so I'm gonna
call that history and then actually know
what well also the history kind of
implies like navigation history or route
history so I don't want that to be
confusing so that's just kind of what
went through my brain with the naming
convention right here so you know what
maybe we'll go back to home but I think
I'll keep it for history for now maybe
I'll come and switch it later as you can
see I'm not great with naming things all
right so we have this and so we're just
gonna use this and our routes over here
in the same manner that we use the
counter context so use that so this is
going to be the router store use context
router store context let's import to use
context and come back to a router store
ooh not router store we just need to use
observer around this I was gonna copy
and paste but there's not really a good
way to copy and paste it so we'll just
we'll just do that and then we need to
import this from the mob x-lite so that
is this one right here for a reason it
doesn't autocomplete well for me at
least when I do like control space just
kidding it work today so actually we're
good to go and so what I'm thinking here
is we'll just conditionally render stuff
based on what the router store value is
so if I go to I'm gonna create a new
folder now which I'm gonna call modules
inside of there I'm gonna call create a
history you know what yeah that's
confusing
let's just call it home no I'll call
workout history there we go
that's what I should really just do to
make it super clear
so we'll say workout history and here
I'm gonna say export to Const workout
history and I should really one I
already have a oh this would be TSX TSX
I forgot I have the RH thing that I was
going to use this is my template they
just create a react talk or a snippet so
let's use that to just save us a little
typing workout history and so the
workout history is just gonna say few
texts workout history page for now and
pour all that import the text as well
and we're gonna have just empty props
for now give that a save and then the
other screen is gonna be the current
workout tsx and you know we could just
copy what we have over here because
we're gonna do the same thing and just
rename it they'll be the fastest a nice
misspelled page but that is okay current
workout page and let's rename that
current workout page okay so let's just
recap what we have so far I made a dummy
component called current workout I
created another dummy component called
workout history and these are basically
in represent the pages of our
application we have a mob X store that's
going to store which page we're actually
rendering and using this path and maybe
path is not the best name really it
should be like I guess it's a screen is
the best name for it I suppose and then
routes over here this is what's going to
display and you know instead of routes
we could really call it router I think
that makes more sense because that's
really what it's doing
so what we're gonna do here is basically
decide which one we're gonna render so
here in say router store dot screen is
equal to workouts history and you know
what I should make this this a type a
union type and then we get Auto
completion so you can say routes workout
history it's really the only route right
now all right so now if I do that I
think we should get Auto completion here
yeah so pretty cool you get Auto
completion on strings because it knows
that the only possible type this can be
his workout history so there we go
so if it's equal to workout history
we're gonna render the workout history
screen otherwise we're gonna just render
the current workout current workout page
I just want to call it current workout
not current workout page so let me get
rid of that so we'll rename that there
and then that's good there and looks
like I need to import to react at the
top so this router now is what's going
to be rendered over here so we have all
this junk and we're saying export Const
app now I'm just gonna say export comp
actually we should just say export all
from router actually that's not what I
want to do I want to say so what I'm
trying to decide is if I want to
actually keep this container style and I
think I do so I think I'm just gonna get
rid of all this stuff here and do this
and so now we'll have router like that
okay I think I like that so I'm gonna
get rid of this we don't need to
observer here and we can get rid of some
of these styles alright so now what
we're doing is we're rendering our app
which just renders the router and then
that router has these two screens right
here so let's look at that so we have
this it's his workout history page and
so now if I want to change pages we can
add our observer
observer and then we can get access to
the mob ex state that we used or the
router store and that allow us to say
use context and we're going to say
router store router store context and
we're going to just add a button to
transition so this is going to be like
create workouts and actually on react
native you say title so create workout
like that and I'm going to say on press
and whereas a router store dot screen is
equal to workout history oh you know
what it can be now two possible screens
so button react natives will report it
from so let's go back to our screen over
here so it can either be workout history
or current workout and so we're just
going to transition this to current
workouts give that a save so now if I
click that it'll transition me to the
current workout page of course if i
refresh and take us back to the homepage
or the workout history page so cool and
we can add a button back over here it
says like go back or something which
we'll do in the future and this is going
to be basically how we're gonna store or
access the router state is we can just
access it through the router store
context that we created with mob X
anyway so that's how we're gonna be
handling navigation it's just through
this mob X store because when it's dead
simple and it will work and looks like
it is you can actually use this in real
application and def hug has had success
with that anyway guys there's one last
thing I want to do for in the video and
that's just to make this style a slight
change to this so I just want to make so
this wraps or that this is kind of like
phone size so if I right-click and
inspect I can click on this we can get
what the size of like a phone is so for
example we can get a large mobile
phone is 425 pixels so I'm gonna just
set like this container to 425 pixels or
I'm gonna create a new one which I'm
gonna call a wrapper so style wrapper
style wrapper and what my wrappers gonna
do here is all it's gonna say is the
width is gonna be a hundred percent
that's gonna have a max width of 425
reason why I'm doing this is because I
don't want my content to just like
stretch the entire screen as it gets
really big and I kind of just want it to
be centered right here at 425 and that'd
be where it stays so that's the plan is
to have like this little wrapper and I
think I want the color I can't decide if
I want this color I'm in the center I
think I do so I'm just gonna move the
background color to here and have it
like that um the other thing that we
need to do is you'll notice that the
color doesn't extend the full screen if
I hover over this we're not currently
doing or not this is this content if we
hover over you can see that blue it's
just not taking up the full screen
there's actually something in the react
native web documentation about this how
we have to make the height 100 percent
so we're gonna do that real quick
because that'll be helpful so this spans
the whole screen as well so to do that
we actually need to touch some HTML so
we're gonna go just to the web public
index.html and all we're gonna do is
we're gonna add a few styles so we're
gonna say style height 100% is the first
one we're gonna add and we're just gonna
add that to both the HTML the body and
the div because those are all the things
that are not a hundred percent right now
so if we look at the HTML is not a
hundred percent body the div and now I
think this we can set it I was a hundred
percent I think now and then I'll be
able to match all so one thing I noticed
when I was kind of digging around with
this is the inspect tool is kind of
broken with react native web or at least
it's not as good you notice if I'm like
looking at the styles of stuff it's kind
of broken up
a ton so like let's say I want to see
what color this button is it's not
really clear and everything's broken up
into 100 properties so the inspect being
able to inspect and basically play the
CSS and stuff is not exactly something
you could do with react native web
because of that and how many just
classes they spit on to this but anyway
that's just a side note that I noticed
if we come back over here we can say
this is has a height of 100 percent I
think we're saying flex one so I'm not
sure what else we need to add to make it
I think that was the only things that I
saw in the docs to make the height one
percent I guess we have to target this
guy right here and set its height 200
percent which is this is kind of
outermost div that we just did or that
in most view so I'm gonna go check the
react native web Doc's in the next video
we'll make sure this spans the entire
page because we kind of want it to
we're gonna be building out this card as
a component it's gonna be keeping track
of basically the current users worked
out so for example as they're squatting
they're going to be marking how many
reps they did and keeping track of their
sets with this now before we actually
build this component out there's one
thing that I wanted to do real quick
when I left you last we wanted to fix
the height of our application because
right now it's not stretching to the
very bottom and we can easily fix this
by making two changes the first is in
our public index HTML we want to just
come over here and this div which has an
ID of route we're gonna add a display
flex on it and then after that in our
index dot TSX
if we come back in our common package
we're just gonna say on our wrapper a
flex of one and so what that's gonna do
now is this div is gonna allow whatever
content is in there to grow I'm in Flex
and then we said flex one to make it
grow the wrapper grows and also the
container grows and now it goes all the
way down the screen so we're able to fix
that all right so now we're gonna get on
to this component and start building
this now before we actually start
building this component I thought be
helpful to kind of go through how I look
at this and what goes through my brain
when I'm kind of like envisioning how to
build this I know this is a little bit
blurry but it'll do and we can I get the
general shape of everything so when I
see something like this I actually kind
of in my head break it up into a lot of
different boxes because most layouts
what I'll do is I'll break it up into
big boxes and then smaller individual
boxes and that's usually all layout is a
bunch of boxes even though this may not
even look that boxy so let's start off
the first thing that I kind of think
about is like I see the edges right here
in just the container itself I think
about so the first thing I noticed is
like it has rounded corners so we're
gonna have to add a border radius to the
container then I noticed there's a
little shadow so we have to add a box
shadow for the container itself and then
I kind of go into the content itself the
first thing I noticed is there's some
natural splits so for example the
content is kind of split in the middle
here so we immediately see we're gonna
have like a view on top we're just gonna
be this portion and we're having a view
on the bottom which is this portion
itself that was like the first big split
that I saw and so you can already
imagine our container may display the
Flex direction maybe a column and we'll
have this on top and this on the bottom
and then we'll notice this is going to
be a text field and if we look at lists
will basically see there's a little
padding on the side here and there's a
little padding on the side here and then
basically there's a ton of space in
between them right so I imagine we're
gonna do something like space between
there's a a justified content setting
which basically spaces this and pushes
all the space between the items so I
imagine we're gonna have a view here
then we're gonna have some text some
text and then our view is gonna say
justify content space between and it's
gonna spread them like that and then the
bottom view down here we can take a look
at this again we're gonna have some
space in between and we notice they're
equally spaced out and basically this is
just a bunch of boxes again so we just
have a bunch of boxes and they just
repeat each other the boxes themself
have a couple states we can see that
here this has like some numbers and this
has just blank but this is actually not
too complex right so we're gonna have
some padding of some sort on this as
well equal on all sides we're gonna
notice there is a border radius around
it so we gonna have a circle and then
inside of this so this is going to be a
view right and then inside of the view
is gonna be some text the actual number
itself
anyway that's kinda how I like break it
down the layout before I even start
coding I actually like will think this
all in my head and kind of just go
through how I break down the UI and
that's kind of what I imagined each
little piece to be all right so now that
we kind of have an idea of what each
piece is let's go ahead and start making
this so I said the first thing we're to
start with or at least the thing I think
about is this outside container so we're
gonna kind of create that so we'll top
on over to our code and I'm gonna make
this into its own component and I want
to create a new folder here called UI
and
call this the workout card tsx and the
reason why I made I made a folder for it
is because I see this as a piece that
could be used across their application
it's kind of like a shared UI piece so
I'm gonna say RH for my react took a
snippet and we're going to say workout
card and so I'm gonna say RN SS this is
my snippet for style sheets and we're
gonna start by having an outermost view
and so this view is can be that card
that we just talked about and let me
just push this over a little bit so
we're gonna say card and we're gonna
just apply that style onto this real
quick so we're gonna say style Styles
card and then just for the sake of
viewing it I'm just gonna say text hey
guys I'm gonna import that I'm gonna
import all these things so I just hit
ctrl + space to bring up the
intellisense I'll do that other other
thing I wanted to mention is you don't
always have to do the hotkeys - there's
this little light bulb that sometimes
appears you can click on that and I'll
do the same thing where you can auto
importance all right so now we're gonna
deal with this card style so I Ray said
the border-radius we're gonna have
something it didn't look too bad some
say like a board radius of three the
background color was white so we're
gonna say FFF
and then lastly was that Bock shadow and
I actually didn't even know how to do a
box shadow and react before I did this
so I just went on over to her sorry
react native so I just went over
stackoverflow and saw this answer and we
can use these properties to add a box
shadow and then and all these chat
variables we can kind of play with a
little bit to get a better shadow I
played with the numbers a little bit and
I thought with of too height of two and
then the shadow opacity of 0.3 looked
pretty nice but basically you can do
whatever you want and I think I also set
the shadow radius to match the shadow
right or the radius that we used up here
so the other thing I like to do is just
to render this right away and kind of
get a feel for what it's looking like so
I'm going to just go over to the current
workout screen that we
and I'm gonna just render a workout card
workout card and just to get a feel for
it
the other thing I'm gonna do real quick
is a style sheet here I'm just gonna
call this the container and I'm gonna
set the background color just for this
page to be fa-fa-fa that way we can just
see some contrast between the actual
background color of the card and the
background color of this oops we're
gonna say style stock container alright
give that a save and let's go take a
look at our content I don't know if I
mentioned this but I'm gonna have just
like the yarn watch running on the
common package and then I just have my
server running from the web so those are
just kind of constantly running
throughout the series alright so let's
go over to that page by saying create
workouts here we can see our car door
being rendered um the other thing I'm
gonna do is just add a little bit of
margin everywhere so I'll say like a
margin of 10 that way it's just not up
against the edge and I can see it a
little bit so there we go nice other
thing I'm gonna do real quick is just
head over to our router store and set
the default state to current workout so
we don't have to have the screen change
every single time alright so this is a
good start for our card so why don't we
start making the to top view first so I
said there's gonna have be a view here
and a view down here so we're gonna
create those two so back to our workout
cart so here I'm gonna say this is gonna
be like our top view and I'm gonna have
a bottom view and here we're gonna say
flex direction is going to be a column
that way we get them stacked and again I
can display some text if I want to and
just say bottom for now because we're
gonna fill on the top first so for this
we saw some text and this was actually
the workout they were doing so why don't
we take that as a prop so here I'm gonna
say exercise and that's just the name of
the exercise and we're just going to
take that as a prop
and we'll render that here and then on
the other side we saw was I believe was
just I guess the amount of reps that
we're doing and then for the weight that
we're doing it at so we could just say
here will say reps and weight as a
string and it'll take that as another
prop that we're gonna have on the right
side so reps and weight and I guess it's
the sets as well but that'll cover it so
actually you know I guess we is better
to be the clip most clear so uh one
thing I can do I don't know if I hit f2
it brings up this little window I don't
know if it's gonna rename it here and
here let's see if it does or maybe if I
do an f2 here it'll do it so I'm gonna
say reps sets and wait I don't know if
that really uh that really even looks
that good of a variable name I think I
like reps and weight better it just
looks a lot cleaner alright anyway it
didn't really - well alright so let's
add that so I'm going to say exercise
it's going to be squat and the reps and
weight is going to be a five by five and
we're doing 260 today the other thing is
if we look at our workout card right now
I believe the text probably is like all
mashed up against each other
nope it's actually rendered below each
other that's kind of interesting I would
have thought they were do you know what
I think the default might be a flex
direction is a column instead of row
maybe I can't remember anyway so we're
gonna add a style to this that way they
are next to each other or not next to
each other at least on the same line so
here I'm gonna say top row and we're
gonna say flex direction is a row and
then we're gonna say justify well let's
just see what that looks like for a
strain before we add the next step so
we're going to say Styles top row
and now they should be side by side nice
and so now we just want to add space so
this is on the other side over here so
for that we're gonna say justify content
space between and so now it's gonna just
jam space between them and they're now
on the sides so I mean the next thing is
we want to just add some padding and
we're basically adding padding all
around to the carts itself so I can just
say on my card up here you can just add
padding of I don't know like ten or
something see what that looks like that
looks pretty good we could maybe add a
little bit less
it also looks a little Spacey on the
bottom but we can make these little
changes later the other thing I'm gonna
just capitalize squat and over here I'm
now going to just maybe make the text a
little bit bigger so here I'm going to
say top row text and I don't know font
size 16 style Styles top row and then
same style we're gonna apply to the
other one as well all right let's take a
look at that awesome so let's do the
bottom row now so we have this part and
let's go back to our whiteboard we don't
really need this anymore so the bottom
row again we're gonna have a view and
you'll notice it's kind of a row and
then we're just going to basically you
look looping through these five
different things
so let's actually add the prop for that
first so this is going to be basically
these sets and this is going to be I
guess this is really just an array and
it's gonna be the values either I think
I'm gonna save the values a string
because there's a couple different
states one of the states is an x mark
through it one of the states is blank
and the other state is a number of with
a color so 5 4 3 2 1 and so on so I'm
gonna just say this is a string array
and I guess I guess it just makes more
sense to say reps but we are a said is
this really considered reps or is this
considered sets I guess it is sets it
makes more sense I think all right so we
have an array of sets and we're
basically going to map through that and
render them here so we're gonna say sets
dot map and for each set we're gonna
return a view so first off actually I'm
not sure the best thing for the key
itself I actually think the only key we
have for this is it gonna be the index
so key will say it's the index because
there's really nothing unique about the
set themselves it's just gonna be the
number five or something
alright and I guess we could say set
plus index that might I guess makes the
most sense alright so this view is gonna
be that red circle thing so we'll style
that in a second because it can possibly
again be three different states so why
don't we say if set is equal to X then
we're gonna return just the text X and
we're gonna style this in a second if
set is blink we're going to just render
a blank text otherwise we're gonna
render the circle right here and for all
of these we're gonna have to say a key
so key
all right the other thing is this is
also going to be a row so why don't we
just add the style for that real quick
so this is going to be the bottom row
and flex direction is going to be row
and then the we're gonna use justify
content and we're gonna say space we
want to do space between but we also
want to do so I think I don't know if
space between our space evenly it's
gonna work out better well I just have
to see what it looks like all right so
why don't we start with what the red
circles look like and render that first
so we're gonna have some kind of view
with a large border radius so I'm gonna
say circle it's gonna have a border
radius of say nine and then we're also
gonna have to set a background color and
I thought it'd be kind of nice to
instead of just copying their color
scheme to make our own color scheme so I
just went to color Adobe this is a nice
little tool it has a little color wheel
where you can put a color and I'll give
you there's different ways you can do to
create basically color palettes right
now I'm doing complimentary color
palette for just white and so we're
gonna make our little circles this green
color alright so come back over here and
we'll render this color for our circle
all right so here we're gonna say style
style a circle and inside of that we're
just gonna render some text and we may
need to like align this in the center
and stuff and this is just gonna be this
set itself so let's go ahead and add
some sets over here so let's say for now
we're just going to do an array of five
and we'll have that a couple times so
five sets of five is what we'll do at
first and let's just see what that looks
like you didn't I Sayed flex row I
thought just see what I messed up with
my card because they're all stacked
did I do bottom row flex direction is a
row
so okay I just didn't actually set it
okay so we're gonna say style styles dot
bottom row and let's see what that looks
like now all right we didn't actually do
a very good job cuz we need to add like
guess some padding to make it more
circular so let's play with the padding
a little bit I don't think I really made
to me circles like this let's do like 10
just see what even padding looks like
alright so this looks kind of blocky I
think I just need to add like a board
radius of way more maybe like 15 and
then I'll get more circular all right we
got an oval 20 is that as much as we can
go so let's say padding of now 30 that's
like that
alright let's say board raised 30 all
right we're almost at a circle I don't
know like 60 just get let's just get
there I feel like there's probably an
optimal circle amount here I'm gonna
have to Google this after I'm done this
video I think we'll just call this good
for now and then I'll Google if I just
need to do I don't know if you're just
supposed to set like a giant border
radius to get a good circle or what this
is still looking a little weird here
anyway so let's shrink the padding a
little bit you like 15 and then let's go
ahead space evenly
looks pretty decent I think the other
thing is I want some like padding on the
bottom itself I also want to make the
text of this white so this is going to
be a circle text
color is going to be FFF
so this is the circle text and then I
want to add some padding to the top of
this so on our bottom row I'm gonna say
margin top and let's just say like 10
I'll note ends like the magic number
today we could probably do like a wee
bit more maybe like 14 all right all
right this kind of looks like what it
should look like I think let's go ahead
and do the other two states so there are
two states where there's an X in the
middle and that it's grayed out
all right so for us that's gonna be
these two right here and we're gonna use
the circle in all three states that's
something I didn't really think about so
what we're gonna do just copy this the
only thing that differs is its color so
we'll taste that and what we're going to
do is just take an array of styles and
here we're gonna set I guess Styles dot
gray and all that styles that gray does
is set the background color to gray and
so this is going to render some text and
it's going to be an X let's do a big
capital X oops and this is just going to
be a blank there's gonna be nothing it's
just a single view oops and let's close
that tag all right so let's add the
styles doc grey
background-color and I don't know if I
came with a gray over here that would
work this is I have all of them are FFF
this brown could work as well let's try
that out and see if that looks funky or
not because it's no longer really gray
all right so let's let's render a few
different ones so this is gonna be an X
all right let's do that one blank and
this one's an X all right so these are
two different states for it
so this has a slightly different padding
if it doesn't have a number or not so I
think we need to figure out how to do a
nice even circle will fix the padding on
this thing but I think that looks fine
enough the sir the text itself we could
probably increase a little bit on all of
them so we'll come back to our card so I
said circled text right here I think I'm
gonna just rename that to white text
because I want to say a circle text and
set the global font size by the way I
did f2 to rename that that's how that
little pop-up came up and I think it
renamed it down here automatically for
me so just a heads up on that so circle
size will say font size of let's do 15
again or did I say 16 above will do 16
again and then I can set that here so
style Styles dots circle text and we'll
do that here as well so it's gonna be
white text and it's gonna be styled as
dot circle and one last thing I want to
do is actually make this X like more of
a gray color I think I already did grey
here this should really be the
background could be like faded
background because we could change the
color on that so this is gonna be great
text
and we're gonna say color and I'm just
gonna say gray and you know what I
spelled out within a there and either
all right so let's add that styles dr. a
let's take a look now we kind of a great
out X that's kind of the feel I think
they had in theirs so there we go that's
basically the start of our count of our
component card here I think in the next
video what we'll do is we'll perfect the
circle itself also I want it before we
in the video
just see how space between in space
evenly looked so space between spread it
to the edges maybe that's better I think
that'd fit more to what this was doing
whereas on the edges yeah I think that
was closer to what this was like so yeah
we're gonna make this interactive and
actually respond till for example clicks
and we'll also get the circles working
so we're gonna start by making these
ovals into circles thank you guys in the
comments for suggestions on how to do
that and then we're gonna be making them
interactive so when you actually click
on them they're gonna change and then
lastly I got a cool ma box tip in the
comments as well that we're gonna
implement we're gonna be doing a routes
tour that we're gonna set up today so
start off let's go ahead and fix C
circles so we're gonna go over to our
circle style and we're going to remove
the padding instead of padding just
doing a height and width so a height of
50 and a width of 50 and then the
recommendation was to do half of the
height / width as our border radius so
in this case we'll do 25 so if we come
back over here you'll notice the art way
more circular now the number itself is
now off the plane we can fix that by
coming over to the circle text and just
saying margin Auto give that a save and
now we have it centered the other thing
I wanted to mention real quick is this
gray that we put in there is kind of
hard to read so I just went into the
color wheel that we use yesterday pasted
the brown that we're using and basically
just replace it with this
so just picked a different complementary
color and seems to work better so I'm
going to just replace the gray text that
we were using so paste that in and
that's what it looks like and you can
see it still has that kind of faded view
but it's a little bit more readable
alright so let's start with this root
store that I was talking about we'll
start with that so the idea with this is
we want to be able to access multiple
stores so in our mob X we have a router
store and a workout store and we want to
access both of them and so one way to
access both of them is for example we
could say use context and we could say
our workout store here in our router
storm just have use context twice but
downside this we could have used context
a bunch of times so it's kind of
repetitive and also we may want to use
the router store inside of the workout
store or be able to access the data and
vice versa so as the what we're going to
set up with the Route store it's going
to give us access
those things an easy way to access all
the stores and also away for the stores
to see each other so we're gonna create
a file in our stores called root store
TS and I'm gonna say export class root
store and the idea of this is we're
gonna be creating a field on the root
store for every single store that we
have so I'm going to say router store
and we're just gonna say is a new router
store and we need to export it export
and we're no longer Annie gonna need the
context which will at the router store
context because we're just gonna create
a single context for the root store so
gonna remove that I'm gonna remove it
from the workouts door as well and
export it alright so back to a root so
we have a router store and then we're
gonna be passing in this which I'll
explain in a second so we're gonna do a
workout store here as well alright so
the reason why we're passing in this is
that way we can access the all the
different stores that are on there to be
able to get this work to work we just
need to go over to our router store and
accept this as a constructor so let me
just save all these files come over to
routers drawer and here we're gonna say
constructor and here we're going to take
a route store as the prop or really this
is just the first parameter the
constructor I'm going to say root store
I'm gonna say this dot root store is
equal to read store and so what we get
from this well actually let's add the
type up here
so root store is a root store so the
advantage is now we can access it by
saying this dot and roost or dot and we
can access for example the workout data
and our router store if we need to and
we're not gonna be needing it in this
video but we may need it in a future
video I'm gonna have copied this over
and just paste this into the work
as well all right and we're just going
to import these and then back to our
root store we're just going to create a
context from it so we say export kant's
root store context is equal to create
context and a new root store so now how
we actually use this Center application
we can go back to our router here we're
gonna call this root store instead say
root store context and now we just a
root store dot outer store to access it
but if we wanted to we also have access
now to our workout store so now we don't
have to spam a bunch of contexts we just
access it through that and then we're
just gonna do the same thing in our
workout history that's the other place
we're using the router store alright and
oops that should be root store dot
router store then let's import those
give it a save and we're good to go
alright so let's just make sure we
didn't break anything
if we come back over here and we see
everything nicely I mean that we didn't
really break it it's compiling
everything's good
all right so that's the root store
method or I guess you'd say abstraction
I guess so
next up we're gonna make this
interactive so to make this interactive
we want to start storing stuff in our
workout store basically we want to store
the current workout and when the user
clicks we're gonna decrement the amount
of reps that they actually did on that
workout so for example this means that
they did five reps of the squat all
right so we're come back over here I'm
gonna make these fields observable
observable and I'm just going to copy
that and add it to each field and let's
add a space paste that and
all right and with that all right so now
I made each one of these observable
we're gonna have an extra field on here
and this is gonna be like the current
exercises that the user is doing so I'm
going to say current exercises and this
is going to be an array so I'm gonna
make the call this current exercise so
we're gonna create this type and it's
going to be an array and at first the
array is going to be empty so let's
create an interface for this current
exercise and for this we're gonna have a
few things so we're gonna have the
weight which is going to be a number
we're gonna have the number of reps so
num reps we have the number of sets and
actually we're just gonna say reps I
think instead of num reps I think that
makes more sense
and then the exercise itself which is
just going to be a string so that's
French all the data that we need to know
about this so we're just gonna head on
over to our workout history and we're
gonna just create a add on to this
current exercise array so here whenever
we transition screens right here we're
just gonna say root Store dot two
workouts tour dots current exercises dot
push so we're just gonna add a few
exercises for them to do right before we
move to this screen so oh there's one
other thing that we need to add to that
we need to keep track of the sets that
they're doing so sets is going to be an
array of strings all right so here we're
gonna say the name or the exercise it's
gonna be squat the number of sets is
going to be five the reps is going to be
five now the sets is going to be an
array that looks something like this so
5 5 5
and I think later on we're gonna make a
function to automatically create this
for us but we'll hard-code it for now
and the wait we're gonna do at 260 today
and so if we wanted to we could do this
a couple times and I think with push you
can actually make this into a single
call so if I just do a comma there you
do it like this and we can do another
exercise so say we want to do the bench
press bench press we're do five five and
then the weight I'm only gonna do 200 on
and then the deadlift we're only gonna
do one set so I'm going to say deadlift
for 360 and this is all gonna be X's all
right and what number of sets is just
gonna be one all right so let's go up to
our current workout so that is basically
just gonna read these values map through
them and render the carts so let's do
that
we're gonna first need to wrap this an
observable observe or sorry observer
because we want to access that context
so root store use context and here gonna
do the route store context and then
instead of just having a single workout
card like that we're gonna say root
store dot workout store dot current
exercises that map and so for each
exercise which I guess we'll just call e
we're going to return a workout card so
here I'm gonna say the key is just the
name of the exercise and we can say eita
exercise there and then the this this
little thing right here we can create so
we'll make this a string template so
this is the amount of weight that
they're doing so a dot weight
this is the number of reps so e dot reps
and this is the number of sets so Y dot
num sets and then this is the sets
themselves so we're going to say e dot
sets so we're gonna give that a safe
let's come look at that and it should
just be rendering a couple cards but I
messed up somewhere the other thing that
I wanted to do real quick is oh we add
observer here we're gonna have to add
observer to the workout card as well
because this is actually using the mob X
values I don't think that's our
particular problem though observer the
other thing I wanted to do real quick is
just an hour I noticed when this was
blank that this was not the right color
so if I come back over here and we go to
our workout history oh sorry it's
current workout you know it's how we set
the background color to fa-fa-fa it's
not showing we just need to say flex one
I believe so it stretches across the
whole screen okay so now you'll notice
we have like this light gray and then
there's this light blue because we have
some margin and our index I think now
wouldn't have any margin here I don't
know what we have a margin on I don't
know if we set a margin anywhere in our
application it could just be on the body
itself that there's some kind of margin
we do and inspect me we'll be able to
see it we set a margin left oh you know
what we did set a margin we set it right
here let's change that to padding
in there yeah now we have fully great
all right so let's figure out what the
heck is going wrong with this oh yeah so
we're actually starting on this current
workout page when really we are never
coming over to workout history and
adding the items to the array so that
just means we need to come over to our
router store and change the what the
basically the starting route is supposed
to be workout history so now if I come
back over here we create a workout we
can see the cards actually showing up so
nice let's add a little bit a margin so
that they are not just like smashed
against each other but we can see we
were programmatically creating our
workout right here so that's pretty neat
so just go back to I guess the workout
card and then and the card itself will
just set a margin bottom of 10 that
seems to be the magic number we've been
using and it worked out nice alright so
lastly we just want to be able to click
and this will be kind of cycled through
so to do that we're gonna just add an on
press now we can't add an on press well
maybe you can't an on press to view I
don't even know if you can doesn't look
like there is an on press property but
anyway we're gonna use touchable opacity
that has an on press that we can use and
then what we're gonna do is take a on
press function as a prop here so we're
gonna say on set press and what we're
gonna pass in is the index that they
pressed and then it's just going to be
returning void so this is the type
definition for a function and so here
we're gonna say on set press and here
we're gonna say on set press and then
we're just gonna pass in the index so in
our function up here we're gonna have to
actually handle this and actually update
the full circle so we're going to make
this a touchable opacity and the X we do
not need to make a touchable opacity so
we can just ignore that so let's copy
this and we're gonna just paste it in
here
and let's just say real and come back to
our current workout now implement this
on set press so this is going to be the
set index and so what we're going to do
is we basically know what the current
value is so we say call it V which is
gonna be the current exercise sets set
index so this V is just gonna be for
example a string that says the value 5
because we're just getting the current
set and so we're just gonna check if the
current set is blank because if it is
we're gonna say new value is a string
amaura say the new value should be after
you hit nothing it should be I believe 5
or really it should be the number of
reps so we're gonna say e reps and we
need to make that into a string so
backticks like that
else if B is equal to 0 it is now oops
not return is equal to an empty string
single and then else the new value is
going to be whatever the current value
is minus 1 so value is currently a
string so we're gonna say parse int V
minus 1 and then this needs to be a
string so we're gonna convert it like
that and then lastly since we're using
mod X we can just directly update the
value now I don't know if we can just
update the value here that we're mapping
through we can try that and see if that
will work so I can say dot sets set
index and that's equal to the new value
all right so let's see if this updates
when we click on anything now so create
and sure enough it does so we can just
modify it there which is pretty neat ok
so we can see we can cycle through that
now
so click that notice click on the X
doesn't do anything but so yeah so how
this works is for example if I'm dead
lifting I basically you know actually
everything should start off at blank so
go to workout history this should
actually start out all blank not a bunch
of fives it should look like that when
it starts and then as I squat when I do
the first squat I'll click it I did five
reps then I did five reps and then here
maybe I only did three reps and then
here I went down to how knows he reps
and I failed so that's kind of how you
keep track of your reps as you're doing
it
so we're gonna be building this little
timer component at the bottom here today
we're gonna start with building out the
UI and then we're going to create a mob
X store that's going to increment the
timer and keep the state for it now the
purpose of this timer is after you
complete an exercise you want to wait
like five minutes or so or three minutes
and then do the exercise again so this
timer is going to keep track of that
time for you as you proceed it's going
to tell you how much time you have left
before you need to do the exercise again
so let's go ahead and start off with the
UI of this so the first thing is it's
gonna be at the very bottom and we're
gonna start on that now so the bottom
we're gonna create a new UI component
here I'm gonna call this workout timer
tsx and I'm gonna say react hook and use
my snippet and then workout timer now
we're gonna render a view and you'll
notice the view is at the very bottom of
this screen so the way that we get
something at the very bottom of the
screen is we're gonna be using absolute
positioning so I'm gonna say container
style here and I'm going to say position
absolute and then I'm going to say the
bottom zero and I'm going to say left of
zero that way it's starting very at the
very left most and at the very bottom
most next I'm gonna give it a height of
let's say 50 and a width of 100% then
I'm gonna set a background color for it
and then for this I'm just going to go
back to our color wheel and pick one of
the colors let's go ahead and pick the
green and paste that in and so I'm gonna
say style styles dot container and then
inside here I'm just gonna say text and
I'm gonna say hello for now and we're
just gonna see if this renders a box at
the very bottom of the screen so we'll
import this and not view base view and
we'll give this a save and then I'm
gonna just come over here to the current
workout and render this workout timer at
the bottom
so give that a save then let's come back
to a react application create the
workout and you'll notice now we have a
box at the very bottom and it says hello
in it so that's kind of how we're gonna
position the box and we have to give it
a height because we don't really have
much content in this but I guess we
could have done based off of the content
whoo I'm just gonna do a static height I
think all right so the next thing is I'm
not gonna worry about the text in the
middle I'm just gonna have these timer
on the left and then X on the right so
this is going to be the text on the left
and then this is going to be the X on
the right so let's style each one of
these I'm gonna start with the X the X
I'm and again just pick a color from our
color picker and I'll just go with this
one and then the font size I'm gonna say
as like 20 we'll see if that's too big
and then this is gonna be the actual
time time text and this is going to be
the color I'll say is white and the font
size a little bit smaller maybe 18 right
now I'm just calling it hello but we're
gonna be replacing that a little bit so
styles that time text and then style
Styles dot X and then I want space to be
between these guys again so in my
container I'm going to say Flex actually
just five content space between and that
should push them to the edges all right
so let's take a look at it create the
work out it looks like I need to have
them in a row so I'm to say flex
direction row likes Direction drill that
way they align and now we have on
opposite sides cool so next thing is I
want to add basically some spacing some
padding around it and basically Center
them so I'm gonna say a line item
Center and then I'm just gonna add like
a padding of ten or something and we'll
give a save all right
and we'll see what that looks like good
and actually I don't want to add padding
cuz UH one other thing that we're gonna
add is kind of like a loading indicator
at the top that's not something you can
see in the screenshot but it's in the
app itself is basically when the timer
starts there's a little line that kind
of goes across so we're gonna be
building that I guess we'll build that
at the end when we have the state in
there so this is basically gonna be the
time and then we have this little X I
want the X be quite a bit bigger I think
maybe like 30 so it's easy to click on
and I guess we want a little bit more
space I guess padding on the side of
that as well and I also want to make it
touchable touch Bowl opacity like that
and then I'm gonna say on press and then
here we're just gonna say a prop that
we're going to take in here so on X
press push and this just going to be a
function and that's the function
definition so it takes no parameters and
then returns void so nothing on Express
I'll pass it in there and so when we
render it over here we're gonna have to
use that on X press
and for now I'm just gonna do nothing
when the ex is pressed so now I should
be clickable so sweet and again let's
add a little bit more I'm gonna say
padding is like thirty and I'm just
going to say padding on the left and the
right side so that should be padding
vertical or sorry horizontal because
we're already centering it all right so
cool so I'm pretty happy with this right
now we can click on this the next thing
is we want to make this interactive by
interactive I mean this should be
incrementing up as we kind of like a
timer approach so to do this we're gonna
create a new store to keep track of this
so I'm gonna say workout timer store TS
export class workout timer store and now
what are we gonna actually put inside of
this right so I was looking at this one
article and I liked their approach they
were basically building a stopwatch with
mob X and so that's gonna be very
similar to what we're doing so we're
gonna take a few cues for how they kind
of set up theirs so what they do is they
have instead of for example creating the
number of seconds that the timer has
been running for basically you have a
date the timer started off and then you
do a difference between the start and
the current date which we'll see in a
second so we're in create observable
here and this is going to be basically
the start time and so start time I'm
gonna just say is a new date but we're
gonna talk about that in a second what
we're gonna do instead and so basically
what we want to do is also we want to
know whether the timer is running so you
create an is running variable and this
is going to be false by default the
other thing is I want to know the amount
of seconds I have basically passed so
for example let's say we started a
current date and then we're sorry start
a current or some time and then we want
to compare the start time versus the
current time and compute the difference
in seconds so that's what this is going
to store right here so the next
is we basically need to start the timer
and we need to basically end the timer
and then in the middle we're gonna have
this thing called measure which
basically is gonna be running every they
did every 10 milliseconds I believe
we're gonna run it every second and
basically it's gonna compute the
difference but you'll see what this this
will make more sense in a second and
I'll link this article below if you want
to check it out because this is pretty
good so we're gonna create an action I
we haven't really used actions in mob X
before basically they're just a function
that changed some of the variables or
the fields in the store so we're gonna
do this start to timer and I'm not gonna
worry about this check right here we
don't really have that problem and no
actually in our particular application
we actually don't want it to function
like that anyway all right so they what
they use for the start time is they're
using moment and so we're gonna be using
a slightly different library for that
it's called day J s so we're gonna
install that and doesn't really matter
what version you install that they are
an ad so just go ahead and do that and
basically day J s's is a moment but it's
not as large it I believe it matches
most of the api's if not all of them but
it just does not have a giant bundle
size and we don't really need all the
features at the moment anyway we just
need the ones that ajs supports really
we're only using one function of it
which we'll see in a second so when we
start the timer we're basically gonna
say we're currently running so we set
the true and then we get the current
time and then we're just going to import
a J s here there we go and then we're
gonna call this timer and then instead
of new date here we'll call a new
variable call we'll make it a day J s as
the default alright so let's do the
measure action oops
should be measure actually I can just
copy their measure we're gonna basically
do that
all right so their measure what they do
is if it's currently so if you turn this
variable off measure is gonna stop
because basically what it does is it
recursively calls itself so as soon as
we say false it's gonna stop running so
that's what that does what it does next
is that sets the current difference in
time so that's gonna be the second is
variable for us since we don't really
care about milliseconds and then lastly
it's gonna do set timeout and so what's
that time it does is after this many
milliseconds it's gonna call this
function and so you notice it's calling
itself so it's recursively calling
itself waiting 10 milliseconds for us we
just care about seconds so we're gonna
do that and then this I'm gonna call
this seconds I'm going to say de Geste
diff and then we just have to say the
unit that we went back in this case
second so what's going to happen is the
ajs creates a date object and the
current time so it's gonna say the
current time difference to when we
started and that's gonna be in seconds
all right so we have start timer the
last thing we really need is just the
end the timer and to end the timer it's
very simple all we do is we set is
running to false and then that stops it
from basically continuing to measure
itself over and over again and by the
way whenever a measure gets called
basically we're going to be able to see
the new value of seconds and that's
gonna rear-end our application so that's
how that's gonna work and then we
basically want to just add a helper here
which I'm calling display and it's
similar to what they did and we're gonna
say computed and this is going to be
display and so we haven't done a
computed property either so a computed
property is basically it uses some of
the fields and it generates a new field
based off of it so for example we're
basically you're gonna take the current
difference in seconds so there might be
30 seconds the difference and we're just
gonna format that into a string so we're
gonna say and also this is going to be a
variable that we want to actually I'll
show you guys the difference before I'm
going to add the
get keyword but I'll show you what the
difference is with including it and not
including that is so here I want to
display the number of minutes so I'm
gonna say this dot seconds divided by 60
and then I'm just gonna say math dot
four on that and I guess I can say
Kant's minutes be super clear and then
the number of seconds right is going to
be this da second mod and then all I
want to do is I may want to pad this
with a zero as well but I guess I wanna
show you guys what this looks like first
minutes : in the seconds alright and now
if we go back over to our current
workouts I want to pass to our workout
timer the current time so we're gonna
say cream time and we're gonna say this
or sorry not this
we just need access our root store and
we'll say root store dots and then we
want to access the workout timer store
so we need to add that to a root store
so let's go to that and we're going to
say a workout timer
and I'm not going to worry about passing
this in because we're not going to need
it so now we can access that over here
and we're gonna say dot display and
we'll come back over here and we're
gonna say current time is a string and
so instead of rendering hello here we're
gonna render current time and if I come
back over to this you'll notice I'm
calling display like a regular function
now if I want this to be more of a
property that's constantly changing
instead of calling it as a function I
can do that and that is what that get
keyword does so when I say get basically
it's gonna call the function to get the
property and now we can use it as just a
regular property and we can access the
field like that so pretty cool so let's
just see if we see stuff and we don't
get any heirs oh let's rewatch now
you'll notice we're not actually
starting the timer so that should we
shouldn't see it ticking but if we right
here on the workout card when we press
on a workout yes we'll do it at the
bottom here now I guess let's just do it
the top I keep wanting to say this but
we're just gonna say root Store dot
timer dot is running or sorry we don't
call it is running we say start timer
and that's just gonna call our action to
kick things off all right so we'll come
over here so you can see it's zeros we
can see our X here and if I press this
you'll notice it's incrementing every
sync it now so pretty neat
so let's take this a step further one
thing is we may want to pad this with a
zero so it just looks a little bit nicer
so I guess we go to our workout or store
we can just make a simple utility
function
and we're just gonna say const pad zero
and this is just gonna take a number and
it's gonna say if number is greater than
ten very or equal to ten we'll just
return it otherwise we're gonna return
it with a zero in front so give that a
save and then we can wrap these pads
zero and now I think we should see zero
zero click on this and increments nicely
cool the other thing is I want to close
the timer when I click on the X so and
that should really reset the timer as
well so if we come back to the current
workout and the on press here we're just
going to say root store dot workout
timer and we're gonna say stop or into
timer I guess so what I called it
we'll pass that in so now we'll let tick
one two three or whatever click the X
and oh it's not can I add property is
running object is not extensible what
happened to this workout timer or what I
do this thought is running is now false
I wonder if it's because I didn't call
it in a lambda if I do that I wonder if
it works see so start it increment do
that yep and it looks like I guess I'm
not resetting the seconds to zero so
that would be a good thing to do but
that stopped it
I'm actually not sure why I need to do a
lambda with this probably something to
do with it being an observable or
something that was causing it do weird
things so in this we're going to say
this seconds is equal to zero - the
other thing is we only want this timer
to display if it's running so we're
gonna say this dot sorry store dot
workouts
timer dot is running and if it is and we
just do a ternary otherwise we're an
eternal reason why I went with ternary
instead of doing double and there is
sometimes I've had problems with that
with react native doing the ant so I
usually do that so we should not see the
timer right away I click on this we now
see the timer and it started it's going
the last thing that we can do is we can
add a little progress bar if you wanted
at the top here that kind of goes as
increments but before we do that let me
click the clear make sure that works
click it again nice also if I click this
I want to restart the timer nice that
worked the other thing I wanted to do
real quick before we actually do the
progress bar is I want to stop the timer
if this component gets unmounted so to
do that I'm gonna say use effect and I
only want this to run once and in the
cleanup function here all I'm gonna say
is root store dot stop timer or into
timer and I'm just gonna go to my thing
real quick and rename this someone push
f2 to stop timer because I constantly
keep typing that and that should rename
it over here an f2 did rename it over
here for me automatically cool so so
with the use effect you notice I
returned a function this is the cleanup
function meaning it's only gonna be
called with this component I believe is
getting unmounted so it should stop the
timer then and then I put a brackets
here because I only want this to be
called at the beginning ok so let's do
that progress bar real quick that should
be pretty easy if we go to our workout
timer basically all we're going to do
here is we want to have something that
has a width that changes so here I'm
gonna say line it's going to have a
height of let's say 3 we're not going to
set the width background color of this
again let's go pick up color from this
let's try this brown see how that looks
and let me think if there's anything
else I don't think that's anything else
that needs to go with that I want to
wrap these guys in a view and then I
want to have a view up here and this
view up here is going to be the line and
it's gonna sit out on top so style is
that line so basically at the very top
of the component I want the line and
then I want this stuff inside of it but
I kind of have some flex stuff going on
so I'm gonna have to move that down so
I'm gonna create a style called row and
what rows gonna do is it's gonna say
justify content flex direction and
Center all that fun stuff alright so
we'll put that here style style zero
alright I'm just gonna see what this
looks like and this is going to be a
array because we want to pass in and a
width and the width is gonna be
constantly changing so I'm just gonna
set the 50% right now so we can see it
looks like I press this alright so I can
kind of see this thing right here you'll
notice how it's getting pushed to the
side because we have some padding so
what I want to do I'm gonna say with
this view I'm gonna have it flex so the
row here is gonna flex one and I'm gonna
move the padding to the bottom to the
row alright and press this and now it's
right here now that's super hard to read
so why don't I pick a different color
let's try this one see if that shows up
better if it doesn't we can just pick
white - alright alright that looks way
better cool and so what's going to
happen is we basically just want to
compute the percent of the width we
should be showing and we're gonna just
take that as a property and compute that
in our store so percent it's a string
percent and that's we're just going to
pass in here
all right so we don't really have a
percent yet so we're gonna create that
in our store so I'm gonna say root store
dot workout timer dot percent and then
let's go create that percent so our
timer over here this is gonna be another
computed property and I'm gonna say
percent and basically what the percent
is going to be is I don't want this to
be any bigger than a hundred percent so
I'm gonna say math dot the smallest
number here the Max or the max it can be
is I want to be no bigger than 100 and
what's gonna happen is I'm going to put
a percent sign here at the end because
this is just the format of the width and
then here I want to get the current diff
so that's gonna be seconds divided by
whatever I want the completion to be so
if I want the timer to run out at three
minutes
I'd put 180 seconds if I wanted like
five minutes I would put what five times
60 300 alright so if we take a look at
that we should be able to see a little
timer that will increment I don't see
anything so I wonder if I mess something
up I'm just go over to the percent and
console.log it and see what the value is
so console dot log B percent and see
what we're getting because basically
what we want to display is a zero
percent good and then it should be
incrementally getting bigger okay so
it's super small right now so that's the
problem so I just need to times this
times 100 so wrap that in parenthesis
and to say times 100 get that a save
click that and there we go so as we can
see it's kind of ticking and we can see
that percentage is increasing there we
can see we have like a little progress
bar going now so that's pretty neat and
then so basically alright I want to do
one exercise it's gonna reset the timer
and then it's going to go and let's say
I'm done waiting I can eat
just click the X or I can do that and
the other thing is when it gets down to
zero and I click it and it goes here it
should clear the timer as well so let's
add that real quick that's very easy too
that's going to be just so when it's
zero and we click to make it nothing
we're gonna say a root Store dot workout
timer dot stop so we could stop the
timer by clicking it a couple times and
going to zero and clicking it sweet so
anyway this is pretty nifty I'm really
enjoying mob X and I really like just
putting these values into mob X being
able to create these computed values
automatically that are automatically
changing as everything is changing and
then we can kind of we basically just
created this measure method that just
constantly happening every second that
is causing a rerender and changing the
time on the screen and the other cool
thing about us using start time is if
for example we were to persist the state
which we're going to do later and the
user comes back they're gonna see how
much elapsed time has happened because
we're storing the start time
so we are revisiting the topic of
navigation today because we have a
little bit of a flaw and our current set
up so right now we are storing the
navigation state in ma Bex and what that
means is we're not syncing it with the
URL right now so if I were to create a
workout this is a different screen
you'll notice the URL does not change
and that is the flaw that we currently
have and so what that means is if I were
to refresh the page or just revisit this
URL we'd start back over here and
there's no way to visit this screen
directly which you would experience with
a regular website oops so that is what
we're going to try fixing today now
you'll notice the reason why I picked
this option in the first place is
because I tried out react navigation and
the web version of it was not very good
and it would be very difficult to try to
do get that to work and also get it to
work with the native version but I
forgot about this one package that I
used to use for a react native called
react router so react router is the
standard for the web navigation if
you're building website and react you're
probably using react router but they
also have a native version and I use
using this for a little bit but I found
react navigation to be way stronger when
using the ACK native but I think react
router is a great choice for what we're
currently doing because it is a very
similar API between the web and the
native so we just look at what the web
looks like we can go to the QuickStart
you'll notice basically what they do is
you create a router and then you put
routes in it and the native version is
the exact same so if we come look at
this
we go to a quick start we're just going
to create a router now they call it
native router so we have to deal with
that but you just say routes the same
way and you deal with API in almost the
same manner and it's not wildly
different so this is gonna work great
for our react native web because we can
easily switch between the react native
and the web version so that's we're
going to implement today so we're gonna
start by coming over to our code
I have the router tsx open in our common
package because that's what we're going
to be playing around with so I start off
I'm gonna just install the types for
both of these packages and then also the
packages themselves and I'm installing
out version 4.3 one and four point two
four and you'll notice I'm installing
reactor outer dom and react router
native and then when this is done we're
going to install the packages themselves
react router dom and four point three
point one at dom and the native is four
point three point oh all right so the
next thing that we're going to do is I'm
going to just rename this current file
that we have router two routes just so
it's a little bit clearer so I'm gonna
rename this two routes and it's gonna
ask me if I want to update this
everywhere I'm gonna say yes so what
that means is in my index file where
we're importing the routes it just
automatically renamed it for me
all right I'm also gonna push f2 and
rename this two routes so save that and
save that over here again just refactor
it and BS code so it's now update over
here so now I'm gonna create a new
folder here and I'm gonna call it router
so that was the whole reason why I just
renamed it cuz I want to create a new
folder called router here and then I'm
gonna create a folder called index TS
and our Sario file and a file called
index dot web TS so this is how we're
gonna get things to work so react or
create react app out of the box
reads dot web files first before it
reads dot TS files so what that means is
we can put all our web related code
inside of these files and this we can
put our native file code and so create
react app is going to read this file
razzed react native is going to read
this file so we can switch them so what
that means is here I can say export from
the act router DOM and here I'm gonna
say browser router as router so this is
me just exporting this import and
renaming it at the same
we're also going to be using the route
and the switch component so basically
any component that we want to use from
react router Dom or react router native
we want to export here and import them
from here so you know this is the Dom
package so this is the web version we're
going to come over to our index dot TS
file over here and we're gonna say
browser router well we're gonna replace
this to react trout are native and
replace that to the native router you'll
notice I named it router here and router
here so it's the exact same name I want
all the exports to match up so you'll
notice we're exporting three things
router route and switch and they're
matching the only difference is this is
coming from the native package and this
dot web file is coming from the Dom
package so now what we're gonna do is in
our routes folder over here or sorry
routes file over here is we're just
going to import from the router so I'm
going to say get rid of all this code
that we have here we don't need this
observer thing anymore I'm gonna say
router and you'll notice I'm importing
this from dot slash router now it
automatically did index dot web but
we're just going to say router like that
because we want it to just get the index
file here and basically react create
react app is gonna pick the dot web
version for us so we don't even have to
worry about this alright so inside a
router we're gonna say route we're sorry
we're gonna say switch first and we're
gonna wrap it and switch again we want
to make sure we're importing from this
package and then we have a route in
there
all right so we're gonna say exact path
is gonna be the slash this is the index
or the first component that we want
rendered we're going to say component
and here we're gonna pass and the work
out history and then we can create
another route which we can say current
work out and this is going to be at the
path slash current work out and then
we're going to import route and that's
coming from the router package as well
and so now we can go into our component
the work out no not that we don't need
the stores it's going to be our modules
work out history so here we are
connecting to the route store and we are
saying changing the page here so instead
of doing the router store we're going to
remove that line of code we are going to
be using the history and we can get the
history from our props and we need to
add the type definition to our props to
what types Europe know that we are out
so we're gonna say route component props
and we're fine to import that from react
router and so now we go like this and I
hit control space it's gonna know we
have a history prop in there so then I
come down here and I say history dot
push and then we're gonna go to the
slash current workout screen so I'll
give that a save so we can even delete
our router store just make sure we're
not using it anywhere and go to my route
store just get rid of it
there we go so again what we did here is
because we have it as a route over here
alright we're passing this workout
history component that means it's going
to pass down a prop to it called history
so this is a react router thing and
history allows us to change pages so we
change pages by pushing and again we
just did add this to our props which are
passing in here that way it just makes
it so it's type definitions for it and
then lastly just recap the router thing
that we did right here
so when we do create react app or we
read this in the browser so we can see
it rendering right here it is using the
router package to react this one this
import react router Dom and when it's
using the one over here it's when we run
the app so I'm gonna say yarn watch and
now we can see this in action all right
will refresh see we looks like we got a
little bit of an error I'm just going to
refresh mmm let's see looks like and
call exception
looks like I had trouble loading it I
think what I need to do is in my routes
I think because I didn't say slash index
maybe I'm that could be causing it some
trouble yeah it looks like that was that
so it looks like we need explicitly say
slash and X on there just to be clear
and now we can see it's that and when I
click on this you'll notice we are going
to navigate the URL now you'll notice
that changed and we're on this page and
we can see this page here now I noticed
we get this little thing in our invalid
prop component expected the type
function but got an object
I'm assuming it's talking about our
workout history here we're passing we're
wrapping it with an observer and then
we're passing that to the routes so it
doesn't look like it caused any like
problem I guess just a warning not sure
what's going on there I don't know if
it's just a you know looks like it's a
prop type warning I think we can safely
ignore this I don't know if there's a
way to suppress this morning or anything
but doesn't look like it's causing a
problem anyway this should work all the
same and now the only difference is we
now if I were to refresh the page we're
gonna stay on this page now we didn't
really code this expecting we could go
to this page so you don't see any
workout data but we can fix that in the
future so but now we can navigate to
different pages like this and it works
like a website you would expect so we
can use react router to easily switch
because the api's are so similar between
native in the other one so I think this
is a good choice when using react native
web is to use this because you can
easily switch between the two also one
thing I wanted to mention real quick for
it in the video is create react tap
worked out of the box but if you go to
the docs for a react native web and I'll
link this below they show you a web pack
configuration so you can get this
working so what you basically add to
your web pack say that you want to
accept the extension dot web KS or our
case dot Web TS for a typescript and
then it'll read it these type of files
so we're gonna be going over how you can
persist your mob ex stores and the
reason why we want to do that is so we
can keep track of the workouts a user
has done so for example when I create a
workout right now and i refresh the page
it just disappears so I want to keep
that data and keep the data as we store
it in the history so if you do several
workouts we have all that data so when
you come back to the website we have
that and so the way we're going to be
persisting this is and the website local
storage and on the app async storage now
there's a nice library that was going to
help us out called mob ex persist that
we're going to be using and the cool
thing about this library is we can
actually just pass an async storage to
it and it works out of the box with
react native and the cool thing about
react native web is it actually handles
async storage they re implemented and so
underneath the hood they're gonna use
local storage and persist it like that
on the web so we don't actually have to
do anything to get this to work with
both the website and the app we just use
async storage here so where I start off
by installing this package so I'm going
to say yarn add mob expert cyst and I'm
installing it at this version and the
cool thing about this package as well as
it's written in typescript so we're
gonna get type safe type safety out of
it without having to install extra types
and I'm just gonna run yarn watch on
this alright so how it works is we are
going to basically decorate the fields
that we want to persist so I currently
have the workout timer store up so here
I'm gonna say persist and I'm just
import that it doesn't look like it's
Auto completing so we'll just write it
ourselves so mob X persist and so I'm
going to just decorate they persist on
all three of these fields and then after
we persist this what we need to do if we
come look at the example here is we then
have to create a hydrate function and
then we just call hydrate on our store
so I'm gonna copy hydrate and you'll
notice what we do is we create an
instance
of our store and then we hydrate it so
I'm gonna copy this hydrate and we're
we're creating an instance of the
workout timer store is in the root so
we're gonna head over here so I'm paste
and hydrate here and I'm just going to
get rid of the comments and tells us if
we're using a sink storage we need to
set this to true so that does it true
and we're gonna pass in a sink storage
in here and we're gonna import create
this is coming from mob expert cyst so
we've created this hydrate function and
then I'm just going to in the
constructor of the root store call
hydrate and then we're gonna pass in the
key for how it's gonna store it so I'm
gonna call it workout timer and then
we're gonna pass in the store itself so
this dot workout timer and so we want to
do the same thing for our workout store
as well so we can come over here and I
want to persist all these fields so I'm
gonna say a persist and I'm gonna copy
that and I'm gonna do it for each one
and that and that
cool so if I go back to my route store
now I can come back over here and we're
going to give it another key this I'm
gonna call out the call just workout and
this is going to be this dot workout
store so basically what is happening
here is in our constructor when we
create a new route store it's going to
hydrate both the workout timer store in
the workout store and what hydrate is
doing is it's checking whether this is
stored in local storage or async storage
in our case and if it is it's going to
hydrate it or put the field values into
these two stores and it's also going to
listen and it's going to save these
values as they change over time and if
we want to we can pass in I believe a
debounce value to this and you can see
that right there and the bounce
specifies how many milliseconds we want
it to wait so for example if we want it
to save on every update that's the
default if we want
to save every 10 milliseconds or so we
can do bounce it that and so we could
add that if we want to I'm just gonna
leave it off for simplicity sake next
thing is if we see if this works you can
come back over here I think we should
get an air out of the box so if I come
to my console over here and you'll
notice we have an uncaught exception and
says this value is not a primitive so
what that means is any of our fields
that are not just a simple like number
value or a string or something we need
to actually specify what the datatype is
so what we can do is we can pass
parameter in here and we need to specify
what kind of object this is or if it's a
list map or an object this is a list the
history is also a list and then the
other one is in our workout timer store
this day J s is an object so when I say
object there
give that a save I'll just refresh and
you'll notice we don't get any more
error there so if now I create a workout
we can see that's here and now if I were
to refresh its gonna save the values in
local storage and read them so then I
can see that and also as I make changes
so if I click on that click on this here
a couple times I refresh you'll notice
our data is saved so as we're working
out if we were to come back to the
website we'd have all that data saved
now one thing you may notice is the
timer right here hasn't actually started
again so what we can do is we can head
back over to our routes door and we can
trigger the timer to start so hydrate
actually returns a promise so we can
wait for the promise to finish at least
I mean it's not showing a promise in the
type definition here but in their
example I believe they were doing dot
then on it so we're gonna do dot then on
it too so on the workout timer I can say
after it's done hydrating I can say this
dot workout timers store and I'm gonna
just do an if statement so if it's
running we're just going to kick it off
by saying
measure give that a save so now when
it's first started if it should be
running then we just kick it off and the
cool thing about how we started this is
we're saving the date it started so if I
were to refresh the page it's not like
the timer's going to reset because we
were saving the date it was off by or
started that and again we can click to
reset it if we want to and start a new
set like that so that's pretty nifty and
the last thing I want to do is just show
you guys where this is actually being
stored so if you go to the application
tab and you click on local storage here
and you could click on localhost 3000 we
can see here is our state so you'll
notice the key that we passed in here
that is actually the key for local
storage and you'll notice here the value
is all being stored and we can see all
the data being stored here and it's also
one of those things if you wanted to
clear out this I could clear it out
refresh the page and you'll notice it
wrote it right away so it wrote it
pretty quick if i refresh it'll I get
rid of that so that's how the data is
being persisted and again we're using
async storage so this will work on both
react native and react native web
because react native web implements this
so we're gonna be building out this
component right here today so this is
like a little car that tracks your
history of workouts so every time you
complete a workout it's gonna show up on
the homepage as a little card like this
now before we actually create the card
we're gonna just add a quick thing to
the current workout page we're going to
create a little button right here that
where can click on and when we click on
it it's basically gonna save the current
workout history and then we're basically
just going to render that history as
carts so that's the game plan for it
today
so let's go ahead and start with that
button that I mentioned so we're gonna
pop on over to the current workout
screen and we're just gonna add a button
and now I'm just gonna add a button at
the very bottom here so it's gonna it
can go between the workout timer and
everything else and it's gonna be a
react native button and we can set the
title I'm just gonna call it say save
here and I'm gonna just say all caps for
it and looks like I just need to add on
press and there it will go away
cool so we'll talk about what we're
actually gonna put in the on press in a
second let's just see if the button
shows up awesome it does so next in this
on press what we're going to do is we
first want to basically put the current
workout if we look at our workout store
we have an array of current exercises
and so basically we want to store that
in the workout history over here and
given a particular day if we remember
what this workout history is I can look
up here what we did this is going to be
a key which is going to be the day and
then the exercises that they did that
day in this value someone recommended
switching it so we have it formatted
with the year up front so I'm going to
go ahead and do that as well so the
workout history is basically equivalent
to a current exercise which has these
properties so we can go ahead and just
say an array of current exercises is
going to be the workout history so I'm
gonna just move this down here
and so here I'm gonna say current
workout or current exercise an array so
basically on a given day someone did an
array of current exercises is the idea
so we don't really need this anymore
this is common it's not really
representative of what we're doing so
basically we're gonna do is we're going
to take this array and save it in the
history at a current day so that means
we're gonna say root Store dot workout
and then here we're going to say history
and then here we're going to actually
we're not gonna do it like that we're
gonna say dot or I guess in our case a
string and so this is where we're gonna
actually say like a date like that and
then what we're gonna set it equal to is
the array of exercises so roots tour dot
workout store dot history or sorry dot
current current exercises there we are
and then basically this array here we're
just going to clear so then we're gonna
set that to an empty array and after
that we're going to go to a different
page and again I'm hard coding the date
here but we're going to deal with that
in a second
and this we're just gonna go back to the
home page after you saved the workout so
I'm gonna say history up push push and
we're gonna go to dot slash or just the
slash which is the home page in history
we're going to get from the props here
so that's I have the prop type here
where the type strip type so we're going
to say route component props and then
here we have access to that now so let's
see this in action so if I save this
looks like either something crashed or
did not push to the state cannot set the
property that of undefined hope that
would make sense so if we go back to our
route store or a workout store we just
actually never define this so I'm gonna
set the D fall
value to an empty object like that all
right
oh yes so this is no longer a list this
is an object all right and cool no more
complaints hit save
takes us back to this page awesome so
now if I were to go to that current
workout screen directly should be blank
because we cleared out that array
awesome so I just hit back and then this
is blank
that was weird okay it's loading still
now anyway so the next thing is to
actually format what the current day is
so we're gonna be using day J s since
we're already using that in this project
and they have a dot format function that
we're gonna use and then we can format
into specific date we want so what we're
gonna do is we're going to say you're
your year then the month and then the
day and the days gonna be pad with a 0 -
so here go back to our store or current
workout screen and at the bottom here
instead of hard-coding the date we're
gonna get the current day here and then
we're gonna say dot format and looks
like that auto board for me for some
reason it says require here though so
I'm just gonna change that to from there
we are
alright so we're going to say your year
year year and here we're gonna say month
month and a day so give that a save and
then if I open up my application I can
see what the state of everything is so
here's the exercises that I did on this
date and I can create a workout click on
some days or some exercises and hit save
so this is kind of odd it was kind of
like floating there but when I move this
it's anchored at the bottom now
interesting so notice how this when we
scroll deeper in the page this is always
there I think I might need to like
change this to some kind of like
anchoring it to the bottom always I'm
not sure exactly what CSS
style we're gonna have to apply to it to
get that to fix so we'll fix on a future
video
anyway let's give this a save and now if
we go to our application state we should
see a new day which is today's current
date for me and we can see the exercises
so awesome so next up is now that we're
actually saving stuff in the history we
want to display them here in card form
so first off you'll notice that the card
over there is kind of resembling the
card here so I figured we would abstract
kind of the logic that we used all not
really logic but the style that we used
for the card here into its own component
so we can reuse that so I'm going to
create a new file here which I'm just
gonna call card and this is going to say
a react hook though we're not really
gonna use any hooks in this particular
component and here we don't really need
any particular props at least right now
so I'm just gonna leave them blank and
we're just going to render a view and
we're going to render the children so
the children is a default prop that when
we say react F see that it automatically
adds for us so this and the reason why
we are putting the children here is
whenever we do card like that and then
say we have text like that this is the
children so we're just making sure to
actually render the children so this
view we're gonna steal the styles that
we used over here
so I'm going to use my template for that
our NSS paste in the card and then here
I'm going to say style is equal to style
card and now let's see if there's
anything here that's very specific to
what we were doing I would say like the
margin bottom here is kind of specific
to it and also I guess the padding was
sufficient but the margin bottom is kind
of specific to that particular component
so I'm gonna remove the margin bottom
here and I'm gonna come back to the
workout card and we're gonna remove it
here and instead we might just say like
container or I guess like card container
and that's gonna have the margin bottom
on it so now here I can render this card
and you'll notice without the margin I
believe the cards will stick together
I think they'll stick together so we can
just wrap them with a card container and
that will add the margin so a view and
then we're gonna say styles card
container nice alright so now we're
gonna come back over here and we're
going to use that card component to
display over here so we're gonna say
history card TSX and this is going to
use that card that we just created so
we're gonna say card here and then what
do we want inside of our card right so
if we look at the thing over here we're
basically taking the day that this
workout happened and then the current
exercises that occurred there so what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to say
the day which I'm gonna just take as a
string so if they want to pass something
else like for example on going in they
can and then here we're gonna take the
current exercises
and we're gonna say current exercise and
looks like we didn't export it so I'm
just gonna go to our workout store and
export this type and current exercise
and that's gonna be an array so we're
gonna have our day and our current
exercises oh you know what did I
misspell yep I misspelled it here X
exercises that looks good actually
exercises with an S there we go I think
that's right Spelling's pretty hard
though alright so inside of our card
here we're going to render those oops
there we are so we're gonna have text at
the very top and again we're just going
to render the day here so we're gonna do
any kind of formatting on that on the
particular and we could even just say
like header is more a generic of what
we're really rendering here they can
pass whatever they want in and then at
the bottom here let's actually first
just import all this stuff and for that
and pour our card and then we're
basically going to loop through the
current exercises that the user did that
day and basically give a prefix of that
so squat as sq benchpress is BP so I
guess there's like a mapping of
shorthand here so like the exercise
shorthand and maybe we should put this
in our store is this type I'm not sure
the best place to create this map but we
can say exercise short name so here we
can say squat is sq and if we take a
look at our workout store I forget what
I was naming them I think maybe in the
workout history alright so I did a
capital S is that so we're gonna say
squat here and this should really be a
capital right there alright and let's
see I guess I can just write them out
because I remember them
so we have deadlift that's gonna be DL
grab benchpress BP overhead press and
let's just make sure I name this what I
think I named it oh you know we haven't
even now I did a capital P on that as
well so let's make sure I match that and
I didn't actually and maybe I should
store this overhead press maybe I should
store these values and some kind of enum
or something that way I'm using the
exact same name everywhere or put them
in a constant variables I mean that
would be better I just should be OHP and
then the last one is row row purpose
being that I just did this is just so we
can have the little short acronyms for
what we're gonna display here so let's
map through the current exercises and
then for each exercise we're gonna
render some text and the key for this
since we're mapping I don't think
there's really anything unique about a
particular exercise I guess maybe the
name we know is can be unique because
what I was thinking is maybe you can
have the same name multiple times but
why don't we use that for the key I
think it's pretty safe so here would say
the exercise so inside of here the
string that they were using was first
the name so we're gonna use our exercise
short name map and then we're gonna pass
in the exercise itself and I'm guessing
it's gonna get mad at us because it's
not one of these keys so I'm just going
to say as any or you know what I think
it actually wants us to say key of and
type of exercise short name there we go
so basically the reason why I had to do
this particular notation so this is a
typescript thing so basically we created
a map right here which it mapped
- squat maps here deadlift maps here
bench maps here right and so if I hover
over the type you'll notice it says
these are the only keys available so I
have to say I can't just pass a string
as the key I have to pass a key of one
of these things so the way I can do that
as I can say type of this and then the
key the key of this means to grab one of
these now the other thing I could do is
instead I could say this is an object
which the key is a string and it maps to
a string and then I wouldn't have to do
that so either one would work but notice
I'm gonna lose the auto-completion so if
I were to say like exercise short name
dot I can't do dot squat it's not gonna
know that that exists because I can't
remove that I'm gonna go with this
approach because it's types it the best
or it's the strictest so okay so I put a
space and then here is basically how
much whether they how many sets they did
and how many reps they did so here we're
gonna say there's an X in the middle
Emrys AC dot sets by a number of reps
and this should be num sets and I don't
think I did num wraps I just did reps
then lastly the weight that they did at
alright I'll just see what this looks
like now and to get a gist of what's
going on and then we might need to style
some of these things and I think
everything should be a single line so I
think this looks okay so we'll go to our
index I guess I guess our index is
really workout history page and I'm not
gonna worry about what we have here I'm
gonna just put the button underneath
we're gonna deal with the button a
different video so here I'm going to say
routes tour dots history dot map
so for each workout
oh you know what we can't map over the
history because the history is a object
so I'm going to say object entries so
what object entries does is it turns an
object into an array and this array has
two values or not two values but the
array what it is is each entry or each
or I guess item in the array is an array
of itself and we can D structure it and
the first it's going to be the key and
the second is going to be the value so
value makes sense the key in this case
is going to be the date maybe would just
say DT there so here I'm gonna say
return and then here I can say with the
work out history as we're looping
through we're gonna just render a
history card for each one the key is
going to be the day so we can pass in DT
there and then here we can pass in the I
guess what else we need to pass in we
need to pass we pass the props of oh we
just didn't import it maybe now we have
the props passed then it wasn't giving
me out of completion so I always just
want to double-check and make sure I
didn't mess something up that's usually
like a cue that I did mess something up
all right so header now the header is
kind of interesting because basically we
need to take this date and reformat into
something prettier but I'm just gonna
display the date right now because the
date here is just going to be a string
and that's fine for now and then we can
make it prettier in a second and then
the current exercises is gonna be the
value
oops go this way all right so here's our
cards so we'll notice the cars are
taking the entire screen width so I want
to first I guess split them so they're
two columns so I'm thinking a for each
loop in this case maybe easier to create
those rows instead of a mapping so we're
gonna give that a try so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to create an array
here
called Const rose and that's gonna be an
array and really what this is an array
of is JSX elements and I guess it's an
array of arrays so we'll do it like that
and then we're gonna say copy this dot
for each and then same thing here this
is still we still have to do it in this
manner where the first value is the date
second value is the value I'm going to
say Rose dot push and I think what we're
gonna do is basically on even elements
so we're need the index we're going to
push on to the array or create a new
array and on odd elements we're gonna
push on there may be a simpler way to do
this but we're gonna say if the current
index mod 2 is equal to zero we know
it's even and we're basically just gonna
say Rose stop push and then here we're
going to push on our item which in this
case is a history card
all right and otherwise if it's an odd
element all we're going to do is get the
last item in the Rose and append to it
so we're gonna say else
Rose rose dot length minus 1 dot push
and we're gonna push on to that and
we're still gonna create a history so
notice we're gonna do this twice so I'm
gonna just say instead of doing it twice
I can say Const history card
and do that so basically what we're
doing is at the end we're going to have
an array that looks something like this
so we're gonna have a history card and
another history card and we're just
gonna have pairs of two like that
because basically whenever we hit and
even we're gonna push on a new array and
whenever it's odd we're gonna fill the
array like that all right
let's go ahead and now render our rows
so come down here I'm gonna say Rose dot
map and for each row we basically are
you gonna render a view and then just
put the other stuff inside of it like
that
and the key here is gonna be the index
so now we definitely need to create a
style for this so we're gonna say are n
SS row and I guess the first row is
gonna be a flex direction or first style
I mean it's a flex direction row all
right so style style stop row give that
a save see what that looks like and now
we're getting much more of a row shaped
or at least that we only have to so
let's save a couple more you know what
we're gonna be saving this and it's just
gonna be saving over the item yeah see
how we're just saving more items onto
this I guess do this again interesting I
guess maybe I just had multiple items on
it that's why I did that I think the
best way to do this because I basically
just want to fill this with some more
items so I basically kind of just want
like a random date is the idea so let's
see if I go to my workouts history is
that where we're creating it now our
current workout so basically I just need
a random date I don't even know the best
way to generate that so I just looked up
how we act
should create random dates and I found
this nice Stack Overflow and I'm
basically just gonna copy and paste this
and just see if this works for the
purposes of just generating some fake
data for us so I'm just gonna paste that
right inside of the de Jas function and
let's start creating some fake dates
awesome so it looks like it does in fact
work and this is just some fake data for
us so we can see some days being
rendered
there's two big things that we're gonna
be doing in this video the first big
thing is fixing this row or this grid
right here so it's not all mashed up
together and then secondly we're gonna
make these clickable and when we click
on them we're gonna be taken to a new
page where we can actually see the
workout data for that day and so to do
that we're gonna be creating a new route
which takes some route params using a
react
router but before we do either of those
things there's a small fix we need and
that is with the create workout screen
so you'll notice it is a long list of
stuff and if I click here to start the
timer and start scrolling this thing
just randomly starts floating in the
middle here so we're gonna fix that real
quick so if I come over to my current
workout what we're going to do is we're
just going to wrap our button or
everything in a scroll view besides the
timer so I'm gonna say scroll view and
wrap it all the way here and so this is
a react native element that just makes
things scrollable and will immediately
notice we have a scroll bar here now and
as we scroll this is visible still they
you'll notice it's blocking the button
at the bottom you click on that so we
may want to add like just a little space
at the bottom so it fits so I guess if
we go to content inset is that I'm that
might be the right thing but I was just
planning on doing content container
style and then setting it like a margin
bottom and like I don't remember how how
big we made it like 50 or something um
so that way it's pushed up a little bit
and you can still see that they're so
sweet the other thing is you'll notice
like there's a little bit of spacing
right here because the scrollbar is we
have some padding on the view and on the
scroll bar so what I can do is say
scroll view I guess scroll container is
a better name for it and we're gonna
just move the padding to the scroll
container I'm also going to take the
margin bottom and put that in here as
well
and pass that to the content style and
that should have an R there and you'll
notice I'm using the content container
style on the scroll view as opposed to
the style this is something to actually
access the content or the view that is
inside of the scroll view so that is on
purpose so we have this scroll bar there
cool so alright let's jump into the main
thing we're gonna do today so the first
thing was at this home page over here
fixing up the grid that we made so
someone mentioned possibly doing like
CSS grid here and I think this is like
an excellent use case for CSS grid but
unfortunately react native just not have
CSS grid all they have is flexbox so
that's our only thing now there are some
grid libraries but basically they just
wrap using flexbox so we're gonna have
to deal with this ourselves
alright so what that said the first
thing that I want to do is just wrap our
in work out history wrap our cards and a
view and what I'm gonna say here is I
need to move the key since this is the
outermost view and we're gonna create a
new style for it so Styles dot I guess
we'll call this card container
and so what's gonna be inside this card
container is I'm gonna say first off
flex of one so what that's gonna do is
it's gonna have it expand across the
whole half so flex one on this one flex
on this one it's gonna split it 50/50
next thing I'm just gonna add some
padding say Paddington that way there's
a little spaced out and we can actually
start seeing some cards forming so nice
so this looks a little bit better and
then maybe we want to do something
besides two because these are not that
wide of cards so we can go to our I per
sent two and we can increment this how
many columns that we want so in this
case let's do three columns and we have
three of these you notice that because
we're using flexbox these are flexing
all the remaining space so here this is
doing a 50-50 split here so what we
really need to do is kind of add some
placeholders in this case I think is the
easiest way to solve this so the way
I'll usually do this is if we go to
where we're rendering this row I'm just
gonna check the length of the row so if
the length is less than three items then
we know we need to have an extra view
otherwise we can just rendered null and
so this view is just going to be a
placeholder so we're gonna create a
styles dot placeholder and we'll come
back to our style up here and first
thing we're gonna do is just say Flex
one on it and you'll notice that's gonna
have it there and you know what we're
gonna apply the same things as the card
container so instead of using
placeholder we can just reuse that style
but anyway you'll notice that will at
least push it over a little bit and now
that match the padding we're gonna have
to use the same thing as card container
instead of padding of tin on it but
since it's a duplicate I'm not going to
do it I'm just going to say stylistic
card container and reuse that style and
now you'll notice we have basically
there's an invisible placeholder right
here that you can't see if we set like a
background color you'd be able to see
it's like background color pink
right you'd be able to see there's one
right here and let's use margin instead
of padding and it'll be even clearer all
right
and you can see here is our little pink
placeholder there anyway you can put
that back all right so this is the gist
of this I also thought we could have a
ton of workouts in the history so I
figured it'd be a good place to use a
flat list that's a component and react
native that it's good for lists that are
long so we're gonna have to re kind of
think about how we have this current set
up a little bit because we can't in this
particular format render the flat list
well so what I'm thinking is to
reorganize this a tad instead of like
putting making a rose of JSX
we're gonna create a new slightly new
datatype here so I'm gonna comment this
out and so what I'm gonna do instead is
our rows are gonna be still a 2d array
but I'm not going to create a new data
type here inside of it I'm just gonna
say the date which is going to be a
string and then I'm gonna say exercises
which is just the array of current
exercises so those this is kind of a
similar data structured to what we had
before a 2d array but now instead of
having
GSX we're gonna be rendering just we're
not rendering but we're gonna store
objects the objects have a date which
maps to this and a value which maps to
these exercises so to match it the names
I'm just going to say date and exercises
here exercises there we go I have
trouble spelling that word and then
we're gonna have put this here date
exercises and same thing goes here
and the reason why we're reformatting it
like this is this is just a little bit
easier of a data structure to pass into
a flat list all right so come down here
and I'm gonna say flat list so first
thing that I'm going to do on this is
pass and the data which I'm gonna have
rows and two things just hit me that I
forgot to do one we may have to have two
placeholders if the length is if the
length is only one then we have to
render two placeholders so we can do it
like this so if the length is two this
will be false and we'll only render one
placeholder but if we have one both of
these are gonna be true and it's gonna
render both the other thing is I brought
a tab up for it cuz I want to show you
guys on the scroll view that we made we
need to set this keyboard should persist
taps what this does is sometimes in
scroll lists you have terrible tapping
on things and we want to tap on the
items in that scroll list so we can get
around that problem by passing in always
and I'll link the docs if you want to
see the other options you can pass to
this and this allows you to tap and it
not and have it work correctly but
anyway back with the flat list we're
passing in our rows and with a flat list
let's import this and if you didn't see
that flawless coming from react native
itself so there is a prop on here called
key extractor so what key extractor does
is it takes one of the items so in this
case I'm just going to say item and if
we look at what the item is we can hover
over it and see you'll notice this is an
array of dates slash exercises and we
need to return a string that is a unique
key so I think what I wanted to use for
the unique key is the dates and I want
something like if I have three dates I
think I want to have something like this
so date one and then like a space state
two and date three all on a string so we
have an array so I think a good way to
take that array and turn it into string
is to use the reduce function so we can
say item dot reduce so this is an array
function the first parameter is a
function that takes the previous value
and the current value and then we have
to return something and then the second
value of this is our initial state which
in this case is an empty string so how
the reduce function works is it's going
to call the function that you pass in
for each item and each item it's going
to pass in for the current value and
then previous value is going to be
either the initial value or whatever was
returned before so what that means is
we're gonna say previous value plus for
the space between it the current value
so all that's going to do is it's going
to make a string that looks like this
and it's going to pend the three dates
together and then lastly we need to
render the item for this and this is
really what the row is going to look
like so we can copy what we have here up
here and then this is going to be item
is the key to access and you'll see same
thing as we are dealing with before now
we don't have to actually pass a key to
this because that's what key extractor
does all right so we're going to keep
this and all we're going to do here is
kind of a mix of what this and what we
did up here so I'm going to uncomment
this and bring it down here so to render
this all we did was loop through the
exercises so here I'm going to say item
dot map and for each one we're gonna
render this and so here I can say date
and exercises
so the key is going to be a date the
header is going to be date as well and
this is going to be exercises and we
just need to import that so we don't
need this we're gonna need this these
two placeholder things here still
because this is gonna we're still gonna
need placeholders because we have odd
numbers out or whatever
alright so item and I don't get that as
safe so I don't think we'll see anything
different here and let's see did I mess
something up pretty badly I think this
looks good here we don't need this
anymore I think that could have been
what's causing yeah that look like it
was what's causing the problem and this
is the same two children was the same
key object object object that's because
I didn't say current value dot date okay
so current value is if we hover over it
we can even see is the object it's the
date which is string and the exercises
we have access to so we want to use the
date pin that and then previous value
again is whatever we have on there and
you can hover over it you know it's just
a string it's gonna be this and then
it's gonna be whatever we turn return
before it as it kind of maps over each
item all right so you'll notice it looks
the exact same but is now in a flat list
meaning it will work better with long
lists of data so last thing that I want
to do is make these clickable so and
basically take you to a new screen when
you click on it and I'm just going to
get rid of this comment it's not
relevant anymore
get rid of this as well okay so to make
these clickable we can go over to our
card and we're going to take an optional
prop called on press
and we use the question mark to say it's
question possibly undefined and here
we're gonna say on press so if they pass
in a on press we're going to use a
touchable opacity instead of a regular
view that way it has a nice on click and
we can still use the same style card so
it's gonna look like a card but now it's
clickable all right
so now in our workout history over here
I can pass an on press to this guy right
here or actually I guess because our
history card underneath uses yeah uses a
card right here so I guess it would work
like that so I guess I can just use the
the header which is a date I'll just
think in my head I guess we want to pass
the on press here I think we want to add
an on press here though I was thinking
whether we want to put the logic in the
history card or move it up and I think I
want to move it up to put it here
instead of past you putting the logic of
how the changing of page works so in
that case we're going to pass a prop
down call on press and we're gonna pass
that in here
so now in our workout history we're
gonna define at what unpress does here
in this case is gonna say history dot
push and let's see if we have active we
have history imported and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go to slash
workout slash and we're gonna do the
current date so I'm gonna go like this
and make this a bracketed function and
let me so lets me save and reformat it
so what I want is I would like to have
the year here than the month in the day
of of the workout so to do that we have
the date and it is separated by dashes
so I'm going to say date dot split by
the dash and so here we're gonna say
parts dot date we're sorry parts dot
zero for the year and then the month and
then the day sorry this should be one
this should be two okay so we haven't
actually created that route but we can
go ahead and click on this and it should
take us to a different page and it
should have the slash on it so something
did not work so I'm just gonna see if
this on press is getting called pressed
alright and it is not being called so
let's just go one deeper to the history
card this and then our card click on
that oh I forgot to pass on press
to the touchable opacity here all right
so let's click on this should take us to
20 18 11 18 2011 18 awesome so it's
gonna be actually really easy to render
the what goes here
so let's first create the route for it
so we're gonna go over to our routes
create a new one here I'm gonna say
slash work out slash year and by the way
this is how you do variables in react
router so this is a variable in the URL
the year the month and the day and this
is gonna render the current work out
component so in our current work out now
we're gonna take some things from the
loops from the the URL so now to tell
react router that we have some things
that we expect in the URL we're gonna
say your string month string and a
string now these may not be there if
someone comes from the current work out
so if we go back not that two routes
you'll notice that we are rendering the
current work out both on a route that
looks like this and a route that looks
like that so it's possible that someone
came here with no route params on there
so that's why I did undefined at the top
here because they can possibly be
undefined and so we can have access to
those variables by saying match and then
params and there's gonna be a day a
month and a year and then here now I'm
just gonna see if this throws an error
okay good I didn't know if it was gonna
complain I didn't know if it was gonna
complain because we have the Purdy
structuring these and they're undefined
on the current ooh we didn't go to
current work out slash current work out
there we go okay yeah I didn't complain
because the params are gonna be
undefined and we're destructuring them
here so I didn't know if it was gonna be
upset about that but it looks like it's
go care so I'm gonna make a variable
is current work out so we could rename
this thing because this really is just
the display for the workout it may not
be the current workout so it's the
current workout if there's not a year
and there's not a month and there's not
a day and so basically how this works
now is we're gonna do a check here so
we're going to say is current workout if
it is we're gonna map through the
current exercises otherwise we're gonna
get the day in history so we're gonna
say date key is equal to year - month -
day and then we're gonna look this up in
our history so we're gonna say routes
tour dots workouts tour dot history and
then use the date key and then we need
to wrap this in parentheses so we're
gonna pick whether we're doing the
current exercise or pick the exercises a
given day and we're gonna map through
those so just give you an idea here's
all the exercises on this day let's try
this day and we can see we have just
these three so nice the other thing is
when I click on a workout actually
that's just good it should update
automatically I think the really the
only last thing is when we save we can
get rid of this random day when we save
the workout we don't need to clear the
current exercises if if we're doing a
day in history
so is current workouts we're gonna do
this logic else we're going to just save
the day in in history actually we don't
even have to save it because it's
automatically going to be updating it
for us so it's awesome
so only if we are working with a current
workout do we need to actually save it
in history otherwise we're gonna be
direct direct directly mutating the
history I believe and there's no need to
actually update it and so what I mean by
directly mutating is when I hit this
right - it's gonna actually save this
and if I come back over here which day
was I even working I was at this one
yeah it's gonna remember the two in
history and there's actually no need to
hit save it's gonna save just goes back
pretty much it's gonna remember that day
so we can make changes to the day days
in history now we can see the values
alright so that's all I wanted to cover
in this video we covered a ton quick
recap is we went over fetching basically
different workouts based on the date we
have in the URL and we use this to look
up the key and I can console.log this
date key so all we do is we take that
and we can close this we don't need that
right so in this case 1213 we look up
that workout in our history object and
then we display those exercises that we
know the user did we even love to use
their update the days in history if they
want to as well
we're going to start off by making a
floating action button now those are
those little things you see in the
bottom right corner of applications and
you click on them they usually are used
to add things and we're gonna use that
button to create workouts instead of
putting that button all the way up here
and then after that what we're going to
do is we're going to start adding
workout progressions or what I mean by
that is after you do a workout you
should increase the amount of work or
the amount of weight you do the next
workout so we're gonna go through how
you can increase that or basically
create a workout plan all right
so let's jump into the code for the
floating action button so to start off
you're gonna create a new component in
our UI here which I'm gonna preview FA B
for fab floating action button and I'm
going to use our react took a snippet
and I'm gonna say our our style snippet
as well and here we're gonna say fab and
the first thing is we're gonna have a
touchable opacity and the touchable
opacity is just so we can click on it
and this will be the circle itself and
then inside of the circle we're gonna
have some text in our case we're just
gonna have a plus sign and then I'm just
going to import that from react native
so now I'm gonna pass in these styles so
I'm gonna say style that fab and then
here miss a style styles got text so
we'll create text style as well now for
the text we'll start with that first
it's gonna be pretty easy for the most
part we're just gonna say font size 18
or something like that and then for the
touchable opacity we're gonna do this in
pieces so I think the first thing we
want to start with is getting it located
on the screen I'm gonna give it like a
width of 40 a height of 40 and then I'm
going to say background color so we can
see what looks like we'll just make it
pink and then we're gonna do position
absolutely I'm gonna position it at the
bottom 10 pixels away and from the right
10 pixels away so let's take a look at
what that looks like here oh we need to
actually render it so let's go to our
workout history and render it at the
bottom so say fab render that and see
what it looks like
alright does not match I think my dist
here got messed up so I'm just gonna
delete it
and rutan yarn watch again
- just recompile it and give it a
refresh oh you know what I think when I
do that I'm gonna have to restart the
client as well alright so what I expect
for this is at the bottom we should have
see like a little pink square so there
we go cool now notice it's not really 10
pixels from the bottom and the reason
for that is our view that's the entire
page is not flexing so I'm gonna create
a style for it to have it flex so imma
say container
flex one and then this outermost style
I'm gonna say styles doc container so
now this thing is going to be the entire
page and so this can be 10 pixels away
from the bottom because we need that
outer container to take up the whole
page alright so and we can see we can
click on it as well next thing is we
want this to be circular so we can use
the same tactic as we did with the other
circles and say border radius and half
of the width / height which in this case
would be 20 so now we have a circle and
then I mean really the last piece of
this is to make it I think we did our
card is to add the shadow to it so I'm
gonna copy these three properties or
these four properties that we used in
our card give it the shadow so shadow
color and then some properties on the
shadow and now we have a pretty
nice-looking button there the only other
thing and by the way how this works is
that
kind of floating above everything right
so we can see it I kind of I don't know
if we should have it so where it's kind
of like over the scroll so maybe we
should push it to the right like 20
pixels and do 20 pixels off the bottom
to be more like there that might be
better anyway you'll notice the button
is gonna be floating over the content
all right and then the really the last
thing is to like get this plus sign
centered in the middle there so we're
gonna say a line items center justify
content center all right now we have our
plus now the plus to me maybe this is
just an optical illusion looks like it's
not dead center it might be to the left
and right it a little bit so if you
wanted to you could add a little bit of
margin on the text to left and right to
push it it's like margin left to pixels
margin bottom two pixels and that'll
kind of push it a little bit and I think
this looks a tad more centered in my
opinion but it could just be an optical
illusion all right so basically this
button here we've now created a nice
stylized one and we can click on it it's
gonna do what our create workout button
does up there so we can go ahead and
remove that from our workout history so
let's see what that was doing I'm gonna
just copy the on press for that button
and I'm gonna put that in the on press
of this so we need to add an on press
that way we can this works and we don't
need this watch man I just had that on
my clipboard all right and get rid of
that and we're gonna now and our props
in the fab stay on press
and pass that to the opacity so now
which happens I click on this it should
take me to a workout page now we're
gonna work on that next is what happens
when that plus sign is pressed so first
off we don't want to just push on
exercises every single time if they're
ready in the middle of a workout we just
can take them to the workout instead of
creating a new workout so I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go to our workout store and
oh by the way you guys just saw me do
something that might have been confusing
what just happened
so I navigated to the workout store the
way I did that I should explain that is
I hit command or I guess controlled
probably on Windows and then I hovered
over this variable and I can click on it
and it'll tell me where it came from
so you notice I clicked it once it took
me to the root store and I hit command
click again on the workout store and
that's how I navigated to where the heck
this came from so that's another way I
commonly navigate besides just using the
folder tree here all right so yeah so
I'm gonna have a computed property on
this so I'm gonna say computed and I'm
just gonna say has current workout and
this is going to be a boolean we're just
gonna return this dot current exercises
dot length and this is going to be
boolean so I'm gonna cast it to a
boolean using the not sign twice
so that'll cast this number to a boolean
so basically if it's a zero it's going
to be false if it's larger than zero
it's gonna be true and all I'm doing is
I'm checking if there's some values and
current exercise so now what I can do is
if root store dot workout store dot has
current workout we want to do this or I
guess the opposite so if there's not a
workout so what's gonna happen is we're
not gonna push on exercises unless
they're not in it workout currently and
so the way we know if they're not a
workout is if that's blank so did I ruin
something oh yes I forgot to add the get
property so we're just going to add the
get name to that and then allow us to
access it like we are here where we
don't have to call it as a function we
can just access it as a field okay so
now I'm gonna go back over here and hit
save that has a whole bunch of junk in
it but if I click on this hit save or if
I just like go back and you notice how
I'm hitting plus every time we're not
adding a whole bunch of workouts we're
just looking at the same workout
multiple times so the next thing is I
want to fix up what we're actually doing
for the current workouts so first off we
should be doing a different workout
depending on what day it is so the way
we have it set up and are to go back to
our store is we have the the current
workout day and I'm gonna set some
default values so I'm gonna say it's
gonna start as an a day and the current
squat weight I'm gonna say 45 and
basically you're gonna just start with
just the bar which is 45 pounds and then
barbell row and both the deadlift are
gonna be kind of hard to start with just
the bar so we're gonna say let's maybe
hopefully they have like some bumper
weights they're like 10 pounds or
something so we're gonna say 65 pounds
you'll start with okay so now with these
values this is what we're going to
increment and the current squat value
and all that stuff is what we're going
to persist and as the user is working
out we're going to increment these
numbers so the way we're going to do
that is
first off we're gonna hinge on that day
so here I'm gonna say root store that
workout store and we're gonna say last
workout type and we're just gonna
inverse it so we're gonna say we're
gonna look at what the last workout day
was if it was a then we're now gonna do
a B and vice versa so there should be B
that should be a this way so all this
does is when we hit the plus it's now
going to toggle between a and B because
we're checking if it's a last time then
we now want it to be a B this logic may
need to happen somewhere else or maybe I
should reword this and say like what the
current workout type was is so if the
lowest last workout was an A the next
one would be a B now this makes sense I
think all right so that's gonna switch
between the workout types the next thing
is to actually increment the weight and
use that here so instead of doing these
weights we're basically gonna check what
day it is and do a different condition
so I again I'm gonna be hard coding this
here for simplicity sake but ideally
you'd probably put this in some kind of
array of exercises or whatnot or maybe a
condition of some sort so we're gonna
say last workout type if it was equal to
B that means today is in a day and on a
day you're gonna do this set of
exercises oh and this this this stuff
should go inside of there all right so
we're gonna say do these set of
exercises and we'll paste that in there
all right so so what we're gonna use is
the current values as well so we're
going to say root store dot work out
store dot and then we're gonna grab all
these current values turn barbell
current bench deadlift squat and
overhead press and I guess I'll move
this outside of here all right so the
name of its squat number of sets and
then the weight here is going to be the
current squat weight current benchpress
weight and I'm gonna just create a Const
empty sets because we're gonna basically
reuse this in multiple places and now
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna say
dot dot dot empty sets and what this is
going to do is it's going to basically
just create a new instance of this array
I don't know if we would have a problem
with having the sets like references to
the same array so that's why I want to
create a new array each time just to be
safe
all right and then down here we're gonna
say actually deadlift is special so
we'll just Howard code it like that
current deadlift and then at the bottom
here I'm basically going to just say I'm
gonna increment each one by two pounds
or 2.5 pounds I guess so squat 2.5 and
then bench press and then deadlift so
basically what's happening is we're
gonna do these exercises and then we are
going to increment the weight for next
week when we do them and then we're
gonna basically copy this and do the
same thing but with different exercises
on the B day so again you can see where
we kind of have some duplication of
things where it may be simpler to switch
this out with some kind of looping so
we're gonna be doing an overhead press
and a barbell row but we still do squat
so barbell row
empty sets and in here current barbell
row and then we're just rinsing and
repeating overhead press here and we're
pretty much done I think now with the
switching so let's see what we just
accomplished so now when I hit a press
on this we'll get squat bench deadlift
and let's see what poundage were at
let's save this a narrow squat overhead
press barbell we're at these pounds save
it and if we look at what we're gonna do
next week squat is oh you know what it's
two point five on each side so that
really this should really be five that's
how much I want to increment by but
you'll notice how the squat incremented
there and we got a new set of exercises
so now it's gonna oscillate between
these exercises each week and we slowly
increase the weight of them and whatnot
anyway guys I think that is the end of
us adding features to this application
in the next video what I'm going to do
is make sure the app works the react
native one and at least on the iOS
simulator and then also deploy this to
netwo Phi now there's a ton of things
that we could add to this to make it
better and ten different features so I
hope this gave you good introduction and
how you can get started with this and a
good starting framework and I invite you
encourage you to start adding some
features onto this get an idea of how my
work switch up the styles of things and
kind of make it your own workout
application customize the different
lifts and setup if you workout to your
routine
we're going to go over how we can deploy
our react native web application to
netwo 5 so this is the website and to
start off we're gonna be making three
changes to the project for the purposes
of getting this to work to deploy the
first is in our common package and the
package JSON we want to add a script
called post install so this is a special
npm script and that gets run after
someone does a yarn installer an NPM
install so basically what happens is
when your installs gonna get run it's
also going to build the project in this
case it's just gonna generate the dist
folder so whenever this project is
installed the dist folder for comment is
going to be created and the reason we
want this is because we're going to be
building the application on net lafha
and it's going to need to be able to
access the dist folder so it needs to be
built so that's how we're gonna trigger
it secondly we're gonna go to our web
package and we're gonna be running the
build command and we need to add the
cross and the skip pre-flight check to
beginning of it to get it to work
similar to we had we had it for the
beginning of start here and the build
command basically what that does is it's
going to take our react application here
and it's going to spit out a build
folder with the basically compiled code
or transpiled code that's minified and
all that fun stuff and then lastly to
get our routing to work on net Liffe i
since we are using react router and the
public folder of our web package we're
gonna have to create a special file
called underscore redirects so this is
something that works with natla 5 and
basically we're saying any time zone
goes to a path we want to redirect them
to the index.html file basically all
this does is it says allow react router
to do routing for us all right so those
three throws three changes I went ahead
and committed the code and then I pushed
it up to github now the branch that I'm
working on I called it prod I'll just
clear that so I called it prod and I
committed and pushed up to this prod
branch now I said we're going to deploy
to
I went on her head and I already created
a net laughs I account I have a net
laughs I project that I created you're
gonna want to do the same thing I
connected my github repository but you
could do get lab if you wanted to as
well
after that I chose the repository that I
want to link it to because basically
what we're setting up here is whenever
you push to the github Orkut lab repo
it's going to grab that code from net
lo-fi or net fly is gonna grab that code
is going to build it and then it's gonna
deploy it and then after you pick your
repository it's gonna ask you for some
build options so these are the build
options that you're going to want to do
your build command is going to be the
following so basically we're just going
to run npm run build inside of the web
package so you just CD into the web
package and then you're an NPM run build
and then here we just specifying the
directory where our compiled codes going
to be or the once it's built in our case
it's gonna be in packages slash web
slash built now another important thing
is I went ahead and just said the latest
version of yarn as a build variable so I
said yarn underscore version one point
thirteen and basically what this does is
it tells nullified to use this version
of yarn I just make sure to do that so
just have any problem with the yarn
workspaces and I just grabbed that
version off of the latest one that I
have on my computer all right so after I
did that basically the site deploys and
that's pretty much it you can go to the
poise walk you can see the the ones that
hopefully published my first try it
failed but he can see the logs if you
have any problems you can go and see
what error you have and you can try
fixing it but after that it's going to
deploy your site you can even give your
site a name and set it to HTTPS if you
want to I can see my site here react
native web workout is what I named it so
this is live in production anyone can
access this so if you want to you can
come access it too
and the data is all stored in local
storage so everyone's going to get a
different version and we can now do our
workouts and whatnot and save them
anyway that is how you deploy it to
nullify with react native web you'll
notice it's not too much different from
a react project it's pretty much the
exact same the only difference is really
stuff to deal with react router in yarn
workspaces now I also mentioned that I
check out the app and I spent about an
hour trying to get it working but I just
ran into basically the same symlink
problem and just having problems with
the dependencies I'm not really sure the
best way to set up since we did react
native CLI I'm not really familiar with
how to get your own workspace is working
well with it I've always used Expo
before so instead of just trying tons
more and more workarounds I was kinda
getting tired of trying it especially
because I saw that Facebook has made a
lil announcement about how they're going
to tackle the symlinks problem and
estimate about a month away so this
issue is created two days ago it looks
like so about a month from now symlinks
should be working so I was like I don't
even feel like trying to get send links
workarounds I'm just gonna go ahead and
forget about it and wait a month until
this is complete anyway this video is if
you're watching this like a month from
now check the date sim links may be
working and you can try out the app
using that but for now I'm not going to
worry about it we got the web version of
it up and rank so I'm happy with that
and this is the one that I wanted to see
the most anyway anyway that is the end
of this workout series I hope you guys
liked it and until next time I'll see
you guys later
you